this is Jocko podcast number 205 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick
good evening echo good evening and with
us once again is a SOG warrior dick
Thompson and he we started on podcast
203 so if you haven't listened to that
one yet go back and listen to 203 and we
talked for about three hours and now we
got to a point where we are gonna cover
an operation that took place and dick
actually gave me a document based on
this operation called called rest and
recuperation R&R so dick welcome back to
the podcast thank you glad to be here
and like I said if you haven't listened
to 203 yet you want to get the
background for for dick Thompson SOG
warrior and we're gonna jump into this
mission
once again the titleist document that
dick gave me is rest and recuperation
and I'll jump right into it as my eyes
opened and I became conscious of the
world around me I could hear the buzzing
of a large fly some muffled Vietnamese
voices outside of my hooch and a radio
playing buy me a ticket on an airplane
this song quickly generated memories of
my best friend Bob who had been killed
on a mission a few weeks earlier he and
I had done everything together
basic training Officer Candidate School
Airborne Ranger Special Forces and
volunteered for SOG they'd been to get
we'd been together for over two years
this song would forever bring back
strong memories of the good times we had
together we had often discussed the low
probability of either of us returning to
the world Bob's death had been a
significant emotional event in my life
and one thing I was still trying to deal
with
so here you are how long you been in
Vietnam for at this point you and Bob
got to Vietnam together how long you
been there for six months there's no so
you've been there for six months after
everything that you've been through with
Bob and and Bob gets how did you find
out who told you actually I got a letter
from a girl that I had been dating and
Bob was dating her best friend you know
so we were double dating a lot and she
found out from Bob's friend who found
out from Bob's parents and then she
wrote me so I opened his letter up and
you know there it was and you know she
said I'm sure you've heard by now and
you know I hadn't that time so this is
snail mail this is this is yeah so the
family had been notified then the
girlfriend hadn't been notified and in
the girlfriend rights you were talking
you didn't find out for a month yeah at
least that's kind of crazy
I mean that's crazy that yeah thanks for
flow back well not only that and this is
something that Tilton I talked about was
you guys didn't always get the best
turnover of information because that
everything was so secret so this is an
example of everything so secret that
your best friend gets killed and you
don't even find out about you find out
about it from him you're hit you're
girlfriend's friend which is his
girlfriend yeah so I mean he was at he
was down at CC C so I mean we didn't
really know what their missions were or
what they were doing so being on a team
I I didn't know what they were doing
down there and you know we didn't have
you know communication back and forth so
I didn't know what he was doing so it
was tough less mail that you got didn't
go directly to you all mail if you were
sending me up Mike my mother sent me a
letter he didn't go to me it went
to me through another mail center in
Vietnam that then sent the mail to CCN
because he had to be screened because
they didn't want anything about
classified operations mail going out had
to be screened
you know so any letter I sent we you
know I've started CC and it would go
down to Saigon it would be screened and
then eventually you know would be mailed
her so now is this just confirming like
you know we talked about on the last
podcast that you're thinking you're not
gonna you're 22 now you didn't think you
were gonna make it to 22 is this got to
be confirming that you're not going to
see 23 yeah kind of got my attention and
the other thing is there's no I mean you
there's no ceremony there's no well not
there wasn't where we were okay I mean
we had ceremonies on a regular basis
that CCN for the guys there who were
being killed
I mean whoever I mean people were being
killed almost every week but you know in
every two or three weeks we'd have you
know like a memorial service alright so
back to this story as I looked up I
could see my car 15 hanging just above
my head I had on my normal sleeping
attire shirt fatigue pants and jungle
boots our compound was hit with rockets
mortars and ground attacks on a regular
enough basis that you had to be prepared
to react quickly although it was only a
little after 9 o'clock in the morning
the temperature inside my room was
already in the 90s and I was soaked with
sweat my mind began to travel back
through the past two weeks and recall
how my team had barely escaped the NVA
during the last mission we had made it
back to our compound in Danang and spent
the last two days undergoing a very
intense debriefing session conducted by
our intelligence team in an effort to
collect all the information they could
about our mission the next two days were
mine for R&R rest and recuperation
before we began preparing for another
mission my plan was to sleep late each
morning eat real food take several
showers
and rest we had a saying that denying is
all right and it had a lot of meaning
right now of course everything is
relative so there you go you finally got
a couple days downtime you're gonna heat
some steak and enjoy yourself this was a
Sunday morning in the mess hall
served as served breakfast until lunch
soon I was eating and looking forward to
the evening meal our mess sergeant
always managed to have plenty of t-bone
steaks every Sunday evening
no one asked where he got them because
it was certainly not standard rations
for a combat unit everyone could grill
his steak to his own perfection this was
something we all looked forward to when
you've been on mission for several days
or weeks eating one meal a day usually
rice and fish heads this was a feast so
you're living large oh yeah that's great
after I finished breakfast experience
told me that I'd better go make myself
invisible until it was time to go back
to work if you could be seen you could
be given work to do while you're on R&R
I decided to go off limp to an
off-limits section of the Nang where we
had a safe house the safe house was a
secret location
CCN our unit owned and protected it was
heavily guarded by mercenaries and only
accessible to by our people might get
out of jail free card which was a
special card that authorized us to
travel in civilian clothes clothes carry
concealed weapons enter classified in
restricted areas etc would allow me to
travel into this area of Danang even
during curfew this would be my best
chance of enjoying the next two days
everything was looking good and I was
beginning to relax so you get the little
get-out-of-jail-free card huh yeah I'm
not sure everyone had them but I know
some of us did and it basically said
don't mess over this guy I mean you you
couldn't just walk around through the
cities and you know particularly after
curfews and things like that or you
would get picked up you'd be in trouble
but with that card when I flashed that
they either let me go or they would call
the phone number on there and be told
letting go don't ask him what
doing just leave him alone legit
continuing on the sky had become
overcast and it looked like it would
probably rain by afternoon the
temperature was steadily climbing in the
humidity was approaching a hundred
percent this type of heat and humidity
had a debilitating effect on everyone as
I was walking toward the compounds gate
I heard the familiar whoop sound of a
helicopter I could see that it was
approaching our helipad there was there
seemed to be a flurry of activity in
that area I was only about a hundred
meters from it as the chopper landed the
strong smell of jp4 was mixed with the
wind and sand that hit my face the men
running around had placed some bags in
the cargo compartment and of the chopper
and we're now talking to the crew chief
one of them spotted me and began yelling
something at me the sound of the
helicopter prevented me from
understanding what are you saying it was
obvious that he was very excited about
something he began to run toward me
still shouting as he got closer I heard
him yell Lt do you know how to hook up a
McGuire rig a McGuire rig is 120 to 150
foot nylon rope with a large loop made
out of heavy padded strap attached to
the end of it a bag of sand is tied to
the loop to give it the momentum to
penetrate the jungle canopy the other
end of the rope is attached the floor of
the helicopter the rope is stowed inside
a sandbag in a manner that allows it to
feed without tangling it is used when
team members have to be extracted from
the jungle where the helicopter cannot
land the team member sits inside the
strap and fastens his left wrist to the
strap through small loop this prevents
him from falling completely out of the
rig if he is shot or when he is drugged
through treetops during extraction it
would be very uncomfortable and painful
to hang by one arm but at least you
would get out as we ran to the
helicopter he told me that we had a team
in trouble with casualties one of our CH
34 helicopters had gone and gone to the
area to attempt an extraction during the
attempt it had been shot down and
apparently exploded and burned on impact
there appeared to be two or three
survivors another helicopter had left a
few minutes ago to try and help there
were no L Z's in the area just a very
high and thick jungle canopy
acquire rigs would be needed for
extraction so this is all spinning up
and you you're hearing about what's
happening you are what ten minutes from
walking out the gate and being on R&R
for a couple days our last or last night
you know I thought I know how to do this
do it all the time I'm usually on the
other end of that rope but are you
thinking you when you walked over you
think you're just gonna rig it oh yeah I
mean that's why it was actually you know
how to put him in there and so yeah so
he's just saying hey we got to get the
McGuire rig rigged do you know how to do
it yes you know how to do it
cool come on over to the helicopter and
you're thinking I'll help you guys rig
there's there's troops on the ground in
contact they need help okay got it so
here we go I took one look at the gate
about 150 meters away as we continue to
run the plans I had for my day were
quickly being put on hold as my
adrenaline level climbed in my mind I
could see the smoldering remains of a
burned helicopter dead and wounded crew
members and the bad guys moving in for
the final kill time was of the essence I
had to quickly rig the helicopter so
they so they could go to the area and
get the survivors out as I approached
the helicopter I leaned my car 15 and
ammunition bandolier against the konnex
container I climbed into the cargo
compartment of the helicopter and began
working feverishly to attach the McGuire
rigs after a few minutes the crew
chiefly leaned over to me and said the
team is in heavy contact we have to go
at that point I realized I had been
concentrating so much on what I was
doing I had not noticed the pilot had
turned up the engine RPMs
and the aircraft was beginning to
vibrate in fact we were lifting off the
ground
I pulled the crew chief over to me and
said I'm not supposed to be on here he
looked back at me and shrugged his
shoulders as if to say sorry about that
that was a one of those common sayings
in Vietnam mm-hmm sorry about that I
mean it was just I mean you saw it all
over the place he heard people saying it
I mean anytime something was happening
like that it was sorry about that you
anytime something is happening like
you're getting you don't have your
weapon so that's a key point you had sat
down you know you're you're going to rig
this thing and for anyone who doesn't
know you're on your knees when you're
rigging something like that you're on
your knees and you're you know gotta use
both your hands so you just thought to
yourself oh cool well I said I'm my my
mission right now is just to rig this
thing what's gonna expediate that the
most is or expedite that the most is for
me just to put my weapon down over here
I'll get on there I'll get it rigged and
then I'll get out that's the fastest way
for me to get this done right next thing
you know the helicopters taking off yeah
sorry about that
yeah as I look down and saw the
compounds game as I looked down I saw
the compounds Gate passed under me I sat
back against the firewall fasten the
seat belt around my waist and resign
myself to the fact that my on our would
be delayed a couple of hours as we flew
and I began to realize that I did not
know where I was going what I what I was
going to do and was naked I'd left my
weapon and ammunition leaning against
the konnex
I was flying into combat without a
weapon the only thing I had was my
fatigues and boots and a pounding heart
what a Sunday afternoon of R&R this was
turning into about 15 minutes into the
flight my man my mind began to play out
different scenarios of what might happen
when we arrived on the battle site one
began to stick in my mind what if the
aircraft ahead of us is shot down what
if the only way to save them is for
someone to go down there using the
McGuire rig what if I have to climb down
one of the ropes I don't even have a
weapon about this time the crew chief
pulled me toward him and said the
aircraft in front of us has been shot
down the team is still in heavy contact
and cannot go to the crash site we'll be
there in about ten minutes the pucker
factor just increased significantly my
premonition was becoming a reality I as
I was thinking I saw this play out it
was like watching a video mm-hmm I mean
I could see the whole thing just taking
place as premonition this is this is
what's going to happen and when he told
me hey that aircraft is down
I told him because I had said something
him already I said it's happening it's
starting now yeah this is this is a
crazy thought that you say to yourself
what if the aircraft ahead of us get
shot down and then seconds later he
looks at you and says the aircraft in
front of us is shot down that's a
nightmare going on the crew chief and
the other door gunner test-fired their
machine guns to make sure they were
working properly this brought about a
sudden increase in my excitement level
test firing the door guns always seemed
to insert a sense of morale morality or
tality into what I was about to do in a
few minutes the crew chief pulled me
over again and said it's just over this
ridge line i unfasten my seatbelt and
crawled over to the edge of the cargo
compartment so I could see better as we
came over the ridge line we were
welcomed by bad guys a stream of
automatic weapons fire with some green
tracers mixed in passed by the loud
crack of each bullet could easily be
heard over the noise the helicopter both
door Gunners opened up and began sending
a hail of bullets through the jungle
canopy the most fearful part of combat
for me had always been getting shot at
while in a helicopter there is no
protection the floor and the sides of a
helicopter just don't stop bullets my
arousal level was continuing to climb
the pilot made a quick turn and Bank the
helicopter on its side I was looking
straight down at the jungle canopy and
hanging on for my life smoke was coming
up through a hole in the canopy where
the first helicopter had gone down and
burned as we circled around the steep
side of the mountain we saw another hole
in the canopy about two hundred meters
from the first when we approached this
hole and slowed down the ground fire
coming up at us increased shell casings
from the door guns were piling up on the
floor some were falling out as we passed
directly over the hole I could see the
second helicopter lying on its side in a
steep ravine the tail section was broken
off and I thought I saw a crew member
still in the aircraft recirc 'old around
and came in for a closer look this time
I could see the aircrew was trapped
inside the aircraft and fuel was
spilling out on them any spark from
inside the craft or a tracer round would
ignite
the fuel and burn them alive the door
Gunners were continuing to play
suppressive fire in the position
shooting at us it wasn't really having
much effect on them bullets were coming
up at us from all directions we also
detected some movement that indicated
the bad guys were working their way up
the mountain to the crash site something
had to be done and fast I'm trying to
think of myself if anything could be
worse right now but I actually can't
think of anything worse than this right
now well I knew what was coming so I
mean I had already seen it play out I
mean at this point there's only one
thing you can do you got to go down
there and these helicopter pilots there
these guys are badass
I mean these guys for just to be
thinking with all this enemy fire coming
they're there they're not going anywhere
they're gonna get this done
yeah because they've got that's their
friends yeah their friends are down
there now yeah back to the book here I
told the crew chief to tell the pilot to
go back to the crash site and I would
drop him a maguire rig down into the
canopy climb down to it then climb down
a tree to the ground so I'm gonna say
that one more time your plan was to
throw this rope out of the aircraft
climb down into the canopy somewhere
once you were getting in the trees then
you would just climb down the trees
until you got to the ground that was
your plan my stress level was a little
high so I probably wasn't making the
best plans that I could but at the time
that was the only way I could see to get
down to him when he told him this is the
crew chief talked to the pilot when he
when the crew chief told the pilot both
the pilot and the co-pilot looked around
over their shoulders as if to say to me
are you crazy
the crew chief leaned over and said the
pilot says you're crazy I told him to
tell the pilot that I might be crazy but
his buddies were gonna die if I are
about death in a few minutes if we
didn't do something he quickly turned
the aircraft around and flew back to the
crash site
I pushed out one of the McGuire rigs and
the bag of sand quickly took it into the
canopy we were still receiving heavy
ground fire at this point we were
approximately fifty feet above the
canopy I happen to see that the crew
chief had an m16 strapped to the wall
behind him I told him to give it to me
he was a little hesitant at first
probably because he thought he would
never see it again
he handed it to me along with a
bandolier of four magazines a chamber de
round and checked the safety and thought
great I'm going into the middle of the
battle myself by myself with a hundred
rounds of ammunition yeah and it gets
worse
I mean this is not a good scenario for
in terms of survivability no at all I
don't know are you thinking about that
are you just trying to think of you're
just doing the best your kid doing what
I got to work with we got to get those
guys out I step out onto the skid of the
helicopter confident that I had a
workable plan as I grab the rope with my
bare hands I realized it was brand-new
white nylon rope rope new nylon ropes
are very slick slick I knew I was gonna
be it was gonna be tough to hold on but
I figured I could wrap my feet around it
and make it work the crew chief leaned
over and said the pilot says we're
receiving too much ground fire we're
gonna have to leave I knew it was Now or
Never
I stepped off the skid and quickly began
to discover some flaws in my plan that's
it's an interesting decision point right
there because you got it out you've got
it out right there of hey it's too much
ground fire sorry I couldn't get down
there and instead of you saying hey
sorry we had to leave and I'm sorry I
couldn't go you said it's now or never
you stepped off the skid and descended
into hell I could not hold the slick
rope tight enough they began to slide
through my hands at a faster and faster
rate after about 30 feet the white rope
began to turn red it had burned the skin
off for the inside of my hands and I was
bleeding badly and could not slow down
to make matters worse worse the rope no
longer reached the canopy the aircraft
was beginning to move because the ground
fire had
lifted the end of the rope about 10 to
15 feet above the treetops my rate of
descent was increasing rapidly and the
only thing I could that could prevent my
death was to be able to hold on to the
McGwire rig at the end of the rope so
now the the end of the rope is 15 feet
above the canopy you know which means if
you fall off of it you're gonna go 10 to
15 feet of airborne and then you're
gonna hit the trees unknown to me at
this time our Tactical Operations Center
in the compound was monitoring the
helicopters radio frequency I found out
later that about this time a fourth
aircraft had arrived in the area and was
observing my descent he radioed my
aircraft and asked who the hell is that
the reply was some crazy Special Forces
guy at the time that probably would have
been my reply to when I hit the mcguire
rig I closed down with every ounce of
strength I had left and I stopped the
pain in my hands was unreal blood was
running down my arms it seemed as if the
bad guys had stopped shooting at the
helicopter and were shooting at me as I
looked up I could see the red streams of
tracers coming down from the door
Gunners and the green tracers going up
allowed cracking sounds of bullets were
all around me I was now also now
swinging on the end of a large pendulum
about 10 feet above the canopy
I knew the canopy was about 150 feet
above the jungle floor my strength was
gone it was decision time I decided that
as I swung over the center of the next
treetop I would let go and try to grab
hold of something as I crashed through
the canopy
once again this is ridiculous
this is when I watch a stupid action
movie and they show some some guy
jumping out of a helicopter or you know
jumping off of a cliff and landing in
the trees and and I always go that's
that's that's BS you know that would
never work apparently I need to spend
more time hanging out with you to figure
out what's gonna work and what's not so
that's your plan your plan is that
you're 10 feet above the 150-foot tall
gentle canopy when you see a good target
to jump into you're gonna go
back to this book I looked down and as I
sent her to treetops I let go the fall
brought my stomach up in my throat the
sensation was quickly overcome by the
impact with the jungle canopy I grabbed
wildly as I crashed through the limbs
but just couldn't seem to hold on to
anything I was moving too fast and was
just bouncing off limbs leaving blood
and skin on each one finally I hit a
limb with my stomach and wrapped around
it and knocked the breath out of me but
I had stopped falling after a few
minutes I was able to begin my descent
there was a there was only about fifty
feet to go which means you had tumbled
through a hundred feet of jungle canopy
this is again you might have been
thinking the same thing that I was like
oh I can pull this off until you're
falling yeah thank you girl I was this
doesn't work in the way I thought it was
gonna work I didn't have much I felt I
didn't have much choice I knew I
couldn't hold on to the McGuire rig I
knew he was fiction fly away and all of
a sudden I was going to be much higher
and when I fell off you know that would
be yet at least now I was ten foot feet
above something and I might have a
chance if I let it go and dropped into
it but trying to hold onto that thing I
wouldn't have lasted but a couple more
minutes and then that would have been
out what else nothing heroic about there
it was I don't well maybe in your
opinion I'm giving you about max a hero
credit on each and every decision that's
being made whether it was fallen to hey
when you said hey I'm going that's all
it's all I need to hear when I finally
reached the ground I had to lie behind
the tree for a few minutes to rest at
this point I had very little skin on the
palms my hands are in sides of my
fingers dirt and tree bark were all in
my hands there were numerous other cuts
and bruises caused by the fall through
the tree fortunately I still had my I
still had the m16 and bandolier but I
had lost the magazine that was in the
rifle during the fall
I was now down to 81 rounds there was
one in the chamber I could hear the
firefight the team was involved in about
two to three hundred meters from me
morgue at bad guys were probably moving
around the jungle a feeling of
loneliness crept over me
as I realized that not only would the
bad guys be shooting at me but so would
the team because they probably did not
know I was on the ground I moved out
rapidly in the direction of the crash
site there was no time to waste
I had only moved about 50 meters when I
heard a twig break to my left as I
looked in that direction I saw two
soldiers with ak-47s about 30 meters
away moving parallel to me just as I
turned my weapon toward them they both
saw me and began to turn their weapons
toward me in the next fraction of a
second I had to decide if they were
really bad guys or two of the team
members dressed like bad guys I had
practiced an immediate action drill for
just such an occasion hundreds of times
on our flying range and used it in
previous encounters my decision was to
take them out as I do for the ground I
emptied a 20 round magazine on them it
was a tight shot group and I saw both of
them get hit several times as I quickly
changed magazines I watched and listened
listened for any signs of life from
their position they had gone down in the
undergrowth where I could not see them
my attack had been so sudden and violent
that they had not been able to return
fire after a few minutes I decided that
those two were not going to cause me any
more trouble so I called crawled up the
hill a ways and then continued to move
toward the crash site
that's that immediate action drill that
you talked about earlier take the shots
as you're going down you gotta do it and
you chew full-auto yeah well yeah in
that situation you don't full you just
shout full auto these guys you know cuz
I you know I'm moving and if I shoot if
I can spray a relatively tight shot
group I'm gonna I'm gonna get them and I
know I got hit on more than once I can't
just pop off a couple of rounds cuz if I
shoot it one that gives the other one a
chance to shoot at me so I go for both
of them at the same time as I'm going to
it was the team that you go to rescue is
that another it was all we're doing a
country thing yeah so you know that
they're on the ground out there too yeah
and you know I could I knew when I said
when I saw these two guys or the ak-47 I
could hear the m16 firing
so I knew they it was not a team that
was carrying ak-47s he's had to be bad
guys yeah cuz going in this you had no
any if you would spend ten minutes of
getting a brief on what was happening
you would have found out how big the
team was what kind of weapons they had
all just some just some some little kind
of nice to know information which you
had none of your brief was there's good
guys down yeah and sorry about that yeah
and sorry
after moving about 150 meters of shot
was fired at me I thought it sounded
strange as I'd go for cover it wasn't a
rifle it was a pistol probably a 38
caliber ak-47s made a different and very
distinguishable sound the helicopter
crew was shooting at me the pilot had
managed to crawl out of the wreckage and
this is from the downed helicopter the
pilot had managed to crawl out of the
wreckage seeing my movement and begun
firing at me with his 38 I yelled at him
and told him I was a good guy he did not
believe me and continued to shoot my
experience had been that helicopter
pilots were very cool calm and in
control when they were in the air the
jungle was a different matter he
continued to fire at me until he had to
reload at that point I rushed him and
got the drop on him he was battered
wounded bloody and exhausted and kept
asking me where my other men were he
found it hard to believe that I was
alone I eventually convinced in the
was just me and that we had to get his
men out of the aircraft as quickly as
possible I moved him to a very dense
location in the jungle a short distance
away and continued to go back and
retrieve the crew one at a time
most of the crew had lost a lot of blood
and required immediate first aid they
were all injured as a result of the
crash the pilot had broken ribs a broken
arm cuts and bruises the copilot had a
compound fracture of the femur the bone
was sticking out of his thigh cuts and
bruises the crew chief had been shot in
the leg and the door gunner in the arm
all four were soaked in jp4 a spark
would have made torches of them all I
told the pilot that I was going to get
help for him and to keep everyone hidden
quiet and not to shoot anyone unless
they physically stepped on them yeah I
began to move out toward the other crash
site by this time that firefight had
stopped and I was not sure where the
team or the enemy were my movement was
very cautious because if the team saw my
movement they would open fire and they
would not miss as I neared the other
crash site I heard some movement up up
front and some muffled voices I moved
very slowly and deliberately I heard an
American voice at this point I could
only assume that the enemy had captured
one of the survivors from the first
crash my plan was to move in as closely
as possible and look for an opportunity
to attack and free the American as I
crept closer and closer to the group I
eventually got close enough to see an
American sergeant that I recognized he
was the team leader of the team that was
on the ground was still armed and
obviously not a prisoner so this is
about the first good situation that's
unfolded you got you got some brothers
now that are gonna be able to work with
you in some way I got back down behind a
tree and yelled at him that I was coming
in and for him to have his people hold
their fire after he told me it was okay
I stood up slowly with my m16 in the air
and walked toward the group once inside
their perimeter I discovered that the
loud American was the loud American
voice was that of the American
lieutenant-colonel who had been the
pilot of the first aircraft to be shot
down he was not very happy about what
was going on and was giving the sergeant
a hard time
speaking of stress right you some of
those things that you describe in the
stress effect is you know anger and not
making good decisions and being loud and
being confrontational
so this lieutenant-colonel is doing all
those things you being confrontational
in SOG teeth yeah yeah he did not wanna
do that I informed the Lieutenant
Colonel that I was the senior ground
commander and was now in charge of the
operation the fact that a lieutenant
colonel outranks a lieutenant did not
matter because he was Air Force and we
were on the ground he became very upset
and began to threaten me about what was
going to happen to me when we got to
safety about that time the mercenaries
on the team had heard enough several of
them turned their weapons toward the
Lieutenant Colonel and made some very
cold and serious remarks the interpreter
told the lieutenant colonel that the
lieutenant was in charge and that
everyone would do what I said the
Lieutenant Colonel realized they were
ready to kill him if he did not submit
that ended the discussion so so that's
what happens when you when you try and
get confrontational with a SOG team on
the ground yeah I mean you don't let SOG
teams get very closely bonded they're
very closely bonded to you the 1 0 1 1
you know to other Americans you don't
mess with him anywhere I mean that he
will defend that team they'll defend
those Americans I mean even inside the
compound you don't want him s oil I mean
the compound is kind of like the Old
West mm-hmm
everybody there is carrying a gun and
it's locked in but he's not like the the
regular military units around that that
can't have a magazine in the in the gun
we we were locked and loaded all the
time and he had frag grenades he had all
that stuff and you got these little pods
moving around and they were autonomous
don't mess with my guy you know because
they'll lock and load on you in a
heartbeat but now we're out in the
jungle yeah and they see this guy as a
threat yeah a threat to their survival
to you a threat to you as the leader
threat to their team and a threat to the
survival because if this guy is going to
start acting like an idiot this is going
to be a real problem
so they put an end to that our next step
was to move back down to the first crash
site and recover the bodies during this
time I discovered that there had been
three survivors of the original crash
the Lieutenant Colonel which is the
pilot of Vietnamese lieutenant-colonel
copilot and an American Sergeant the
Vietnamese and the sergeant had been
badly injured and burned in the crash
the second helicopter to arrive on the
site had lowered a jungle penetrator and
Lieutenant Colonel had strapped them
into it unfortunately as they were being
hoisted up through the jungle canopy the
second helicopter was also shot down as
it went forward the jungle penetrator
hung up on a large tree and the steel
cable broke the two men still strapped
the penetrator fell approximately a
hundred feet and landed headfirst on a
large rock killing them instantly we
found the bodies and unhooked them from
the jungle penetrator when I got when I
picked up the American and put him over
my shoulder the air rushed out of his
lungs it was the smell of death as we
worked our way back up the hill it began
to rain so the second one had actually
started to extract the team right and
that's when they got shot down yeah they
were extracting you know the wounded
from from the first aircraft so and in
you might want to edit out the smell of
the effect those little statements just
in case some family members should
listen to this I'm I think for his
parents are gone now but you may still
have brothers or sisters or somebody
just so it doesn't you know sound so bad
mm-hmm once inside the main perimeter we
made the bodies down alongside each
other the heads were a bloody mess and
since we did not wear names on our
uniforms I did not know who I had
carried up the hill at this point I
asked the lieutenant colonel who the
young sergeant was the already sickening
feeling in my stomach
increased tremendously when I heard his
name he was a friend of mine who I'd
joked with days before
I felt no remorse for the two NVA had
killed an hour ago but the sight of a
dead American especially a friend
created a range of emotions from deep
sadness to extreme anger toward the
enemy one of the first rules who were
taught when you arrive in country is not
to get close to anyone but there's no
way you can prevent it we covered them
with ponchos and wandered to where and
wondered where the bad guys were my next
problem was the pilots they were still
out there alone
I took four team members and moved
cautiously to their location and
established a security force around them
to get everyone out I would have to blow
down some trees and bring in some
helicopter gunships to suppress enemy
fire while everyone was hoisted up into
helicopters I had been able to contact
the rear using the teams radio and had
the necessary demolitions on the way
yeah you you went in this not only with
some other persons gun and for magazines
you also didn't even have a radio
nothing yeah naked by the time the
helicopter arrived with the demolitions
the weather was closing in man this is
just Murphy's Law the weather was
closing in the raining the rain was
coming down harder and the clouds were
moving down the mountain we would have
to work fast just to beat the weather
the enemy had been quiet until the
arrival of a helicopter now he could
hear them all around us shooting up at
the helicopter about the time the
demolitions came crashing to the ground
the gunships arrived wiebe we signaled
our location and I had the sergeant
begin to work working air strikes all
around us while the gunships were
keeping the enemy busy I carried fifty
pounds of c-4 blasting caps time-fuse
and det cord to a location near the
pilots I placed enough of them I placed
enough the demolitions on trees and
dropped them this opened up a large
enough hole in the canopy to give us a
better chance of not having a repeat of
the last jungle penetrator incident so
you you I mean this is taking time this
is a I mean to sit there and rig 50
pounds of demo on a bunch of trees and
then and then put the blasting caps in
this is like this is taking what a half
an hour to get this done
yeah probably but you know I didn't use
all 50 pounds as part of just enough to
cut the tree and get him down but yeah
they all had to be rigged he had to take
the things onto the trees put the
blasting caps in and set them off had to
make sure they're not gonna fall the
wrong way but no that's why they call me
dynamite I like to blow things up the
ch-47 that had dropped the demolitions
returned and hovered over the hole as it
began to lower the jungle penetrator the
enemy ground fire increased dramatically
in both door Gunners opened fire with
their 50 caliber machine guns not only
could we hear the very loud slow
distinctive sound but the 50 caliber
casings began to rain down on us after
falling 150 feet they had enough
velocity to do a lot of damage we could
see large red tracers penetrating deep
into the jungle the two gunships were
now raining bullets down through the
trees with their mini guns up to 4,000
rounds a minute per gun firing forty
millimeter grenades and 2.75 inch
rockets with 17 pound high-explosive
warheads the popping and cracking sound
of the bullets and explosions of the
grenades and rockets were exacerbated by
falling tree limbs and shrapnel flying
in every direction the darkening sky
made the tracers appear very bright the
hot wet jungle air was becoming smoky
and filled with the smell of burnt
cordite and gunpowder that's like that
that's enough enough firepower going
downrange like you can't simulate that
did you watch the craziest Hollywood
movie and they don't make it look like
what that what that what you just
described right there by the time the
jungle penetrator reached the ground we
had drugged the copilot and crew chief
over to where it landed we strapped them
on as quickly as possible
and signaled to pull them up there was
no way to support the broken leg and we
could hear the copilot screams over the
battle sounds as he was going up they
say that a compound fracture of the
femur is one of the most painful wounds
you can have after seeing the pain he
was in
I believe it the trip up took about two
minutes
we sent another we sent the other two
crew members up next followed by the
wounded team members the lieutenant
colonel and the two dead the ch-47 left
to take them to the hospital so so now
you just jump into the ch-47 returned
about an hour
during that hour what's happening you
guys is the enemy pressuring you again
she ups are having an impact now got it
and when they saw the ch-47 leave you
know that took sauna pressure all they
really wanted to knock it down god but
the but the massive air support that
you're getting is definitely putting a
hurt on the enemy I mean that is that's
that's a lot of gunfire coming their way
rockets the whole nine yards the ch-47
returned in about an hour
with a set of fresh gunships to help
begin extracting us I began putting the
team members on as fast as I could
while the sergeant continued to work the
air strikes the jungle floor and become
mud and was making the job of hooking
people up much more difficult eventually
there were just the sergeant and myself
left on the ground unfortunately some of
the bad guys had moved up close to our
position and were beginning to fire at
the helicopter we knew we'd be exposed
to their fire as we ascended we thought
we had two options go find them and take
them out or chance being hoisted up with
them shooting at us the pilot narrowed
our options by saying the clouds were
beginning to cover the hole up and it
was now or never we strapped ourselves
on and fired behind each other's backs
as we slowly moved skyward spinning
slowly and swinging back and forth and
watching the tracers coming by it seemed
like it took an hour to make the trip up
although it was probably only about two
minutes once inside and unstrapped from
the jungle penetrator I rolled over on
my back closed my eyes and said a prayer
of thanks there was an atmosphere of
elation as you were flying away from
encounter such as this the team members
were exchanging war stories personally I
was too tired to say much my mind turned
to rest and recuperation and how I was
going to make sure that I got rest
tomorrow the team leader was also
particularly quiet
upon arrival at the compound we were
greeted by a small crowd who welcomed us
back it was a really good feeling to be
back and to pick up my weapon and
ammunition that we're leaning against
the convex container we had been taught
in Ranger school to never get more than
an arm's length from your weapon I would
not make that mistake again
lesson learned to every every trooper
out there don't ever do it not even for
a second I move directly to the
dispensary to have my injuries treated
they treated my hands and other cuts and
bruises and told me to return the next
day as I left the dispensary dispensary
I was told that the colonel wanted to
see me in the mess hall maybe he was
going to give me an extra day of R&R to
make up for this one so you're pretty
much smoked at this point and and I
actually had two broken ribs that we
discovered huh well you know when you
drop 150 feet through the jungle canopy
the colonel was sitting at his table
with another full corner Colonel
non-special forces and seemed to be
having a heated conversation when they
looked up at me they saw wet muddy and
bloody person standing in front of them
the expression on their faces indicated
that they had lost their appetites he
congratulated me on doing a good job and
then he told me what key and the other
colonel had been arguing about we had
left a crew member from the first crash
on the ground apparently there had been
a crew chief in the aircraft who had
been killed and burned in the wreckage
the Lieutenant Colonel had told us that
he was missing a person the colonel told
me to get my team together and be
prepared to launch a first light to go
in and recover the true crew chiefs body
and destroy the second helicopter there
was a concern that the helicopter had
its communication equipment and codes
intact these needed to be destroyed
before the enemy could make use of them
the news that I had to go back out there
the next morning was not what I wanted
to hear I was tired
injured and not sure if I could find
enough of my team to do the job at any
rate it would be a long night
on the way to the shower I found one of
my guys and told him to assemble as many
team members as he could while
showered the shower was great even
though I found three fat leeches that
had crawled under my shirt and attached
myself to attach themselves to my body
they were having a feast on my at my
expense a squirt of insect repellent
made them turn loose so your team was
your team all on R&R at this point
unfortunately the Giardia and we're
still no they were in the compound so
fortunately I guess maybe not
fortunately for them fortunately for the
team later that night we moved the team
members who were going into the mission
into the isolation area and made our
plan for first light launch when I awoke
it was raining cats and dogs outside in
the wind was blowing hard the weather
continued like this for the next two
days the delay gave me time to rest and
heal before we inserted the drawback to
the delay was that it gave the enemy
more time to discover the body they knew
we would make an effort to recover it
they typically booby-trapped the body
placed others in the area and liked to
plan an ambush to get us on the way out
I had been on several body recovery
missions in the past and knew what to
expect the morning of the third day the
weather had lifted and it was time for
the insertion we loaded up our
helicopters and departed for the launch
site while it was still dark at the
launch site we attended the mission
briefing with the gunship pilots forward
air controller our pilots and the launch
site personnel it was a very detailed
briefing with everything from angles of
attack suspected enemy ground forces and
fire locations code words and the team's
route to the helicopter objective
discussed in detail shortly after that
we were given the word to load up at
this point in the operation the
adrenaline begins to flow you've just
made three trips to the latrine and now
you have two and now you have all your
equipment on you need to go once again
you can hear the slow high-pitched whine
to the helicopter engines starting to
get up and get faster and faster you
smell the camouflage paint and insect
repellent on your face and jp4 in the
air and you know it's time
I gave the team the signal to lock and
load put the safety on and climb into
the helicopters the air their engines
were now turning at full rpm as were our
hearts and they were ready to lift off
as we began to lift up and move forward
we received the thumbs up from the
launch team personnel on the ground I
was sitting in the door with my feet
hanging outside so I could get a clear
view of the landing zone on the way in
and be the first to hit the ground when
we arrived adrenaline flown at this
point huh yes and you're considering
this is pretty much guaranteed to be a
hot insert that they might not hit us on
the LZ but they definitely would once we
got down to where the wreckage was was
your plan to insert right on the crash
sites or were you going to insert
somewhere offset we went in on top of
the ridge and then worked our way down
okay so it was an offset how is the
distance two or three hundred meters
okay but it's so far but yeah yeah in my
day we would an offset insert would be a
couple kilometers away 200 meters we
consider that on on the X I mean pretty
damn close
200 meters I'll go then the jungles
couldn't take you some time to get 2 or
300 meters how long would it take how
long would you plan for it to take you
to get 200 300 meters well we're I mean
right from the beginning we're expecting
an ambush any any second so you know
you're back down to the hundred yards an
hour kind of thing so you're going very
slowly down through the air you know
plus it's it's very wet it's muddy it's
slippery you're going downhill to get
down to it and you're just expecting
them to be anywhere in the first life
would you guys be taking off the
helicopters in the dark at first light
is when the extraction goes on when the
insertion goes or are you not taking off
until there's a little bit of light out
there's a little bit of light on this
particular mission
here we go after about 20 minutes of
flight to Cobra gunships came by us one
on each side they were going to the LZ
ahead of us and make a low slow pass to
try and draw fire from the enemy if they
were there on the LZ there were two
other Cobras trailing just behind us
ready to open fire on enemy positions if
we made a mistake if we made the mistake
of firing on the first two we had not
anticipated the LZ to be hot so we were
going to so we're not going to prep it
meaning that the gunships would shoot
them up we wanted to get in as
unobtrusively as possible to the degree
you can with two helicopters four
gunships and a forward air controller
flying around over the LZ so the enemy
is going to know that you're there and
they know we're coming back soon the
crew treif crew chief gave me a thumbs
up indicating the LZ was called and we
were going in we began to lose altitude
very quickly as we made our way toward
the small clearing on the ridge line as
we descended the air became warmer and
humid
we only turned on to the final approach
and began our descent I could feel the
helicopter begin to vibrate and my heart
rate increase we all scanned the
treeline vigorously for signs of the
enemy all of a sudden we were only two
or three feet off the ground and the
crew chief was motioning for us to get
off I jumped into the waist-high grass
and went down into a prone position the
team members quickly followed and the
helicopter helicopters all flew off to
rendezvous point the sound of them
disappearing in the distance created a
very lonely feeling
we moved quickly into the treeline and
set up a small security perimeter to let
our eyes ears and nose adjust to the
environment this is an extremely
important part of survival in the jungle
the sounds or lack of sounds of bugs
birds and animals as well as the smells
tell you what's going on you must read
these signs correctly if you are to
survive after about 15 minutes we
radioed a team ok moving nice this meant
we had not detected any signs of the
enemy and it was okay to release the
helicopters and gunships to return to
base we were really on our own now
standard policy in our unit was that
teams would always have at least two
Americans with them when they were on
the ground this was a team I
in training to operate on special
missions without any Americans they were
still in training and I was the only
American on the team this added to the
isolation effect did they have any
English speakers that were good enough
to call for fire the heart for the
interpreter yeah the others good did you
ever did you guys cross train with those
guys so they knew how to call for fire
with the interpreter some but not enough
yeah I think when you say this is a
lonely isolating thing I think that's
the understatement of the century but
sometimes sometimes my my thoughts were
if it's just me I'm I'm the one I have
to worry about if you're with me now I
get I have to make sure that I protect
you I have to make sure that I get you
out if you're hit I mean I pick up these
additional responsibilities you know
when I have other Americans with me but
if it's just me and the team and I go
down you know I go down you know even
even the one you know the previous one
where I went in alone it was it was an
unique feeling to know you know I was I
was the bright light team on one person
bright light team there were other times
where I suggested that I might either go
in along on a mission or go in with one
or two other people because I I don't
have a problem being alone out there
so I didn't do that but the burden of
responsibility of the other person is so
heavy and it's hard to get them out I
mean it would that's why you have so
many missing in action from the SOG
teams you can't get them they get hit
and you're being overrun you can't get
back to get them and they might still be
alive
and
you know everybody says no man left
behind but you got to decide you come to
that decision point where do I leave
Jocko and save the team or do I get us
all killed trying to get your body out
and you know my position like I'm not
gonna get everybody kill if I can get
you out reasonably I will but if I can
yeah and what would I want you to do
yeah you know cuz I don't want you I
don't want you to get anybody killed
trying to get my body I know I'm gone
leave me yeah leave me up whatever
doesn't matter anymore okay take care of
the rest of the team back to this
document from here our plan called for
us to work our way down the side of the
mountains find the crash site recover
the body destroy the second helicopter
and move to an alternate landing zone
for extraction all together should be a
very simple mission that should take
about five to six hours then I could get
started at my R&R
we moved very cautiously down the steep
wet mountainside with every step you
expected to hit a booby trap or have an
ambush open up on you when went on the
ground no one talked
Hendon armed community signals were all
the team communications we used silence
was critical every foot placement was
deliberate so as to avoid any noise a
broken twig would signal the enemy of
your approach after about an how will we
stop for a break we formed a small
perimeter and some very thick brush and
put out claymore mines aimed in four
directions I laid back on my rucksack
and tried to relax while constantly
looking for any movement and listening
for out for out of place sounds all of a
sudden I heard what seemed to be a very
loud pop and everyone hugged the ground
everyone except huang by saying that
right everyone except playing he had
brought a coke with him against my very
strict orders if looks could kill he
would have been dead he may have just
compromised the safety of the entire
team and mission i took the coke buried
it and then we moved out about thirty
minutes later we knew we were close to
the crash site
the smell of a decaying body was very
strong you could see the change in the
expressions on everyone's faces if the
bad guys were going to get us it would
be around the crash site we began to
move more slowly and cautiously finally
I could see the sunlight coming up
through the hole in the jungle canopy we
stopped just short of it and sent out a
two-man recon team they returned without
seeing any signs of the enemy I knew
they were out there I just didn't know
where I set up security around the crash
site and stepped into the opening there
was no doubt in my mind that there would
be mines and/or booby traps in the
wreckage not only would I have to watch
for these but I would be standing in the
open as I recovered the body a perfect
target for a sniper I could see large
concentrations of flies toward the
center of the wreckage upon careful
observe observe ation I saw what looked
to be a bone sticking up I cautiously
made my way to the location of the bone
while trying to maintain a low profile
another part of our mission was to
photograph everything I did this quickly
and begin slowly on to slowly uncover
the remains of the body did you have
someone assigned for look to look for
booby traps or was it just every man was
constantly on guard and long everybody
was looking for it as we moved along but
you know as I went out there it was me
mm-hmm watch where you put your feet
what's four wires watch for anything
that you know look abnormal you know
could see one thing that helped is it
had it had rained hard so all the powder
and materials like that from from the
fire you know I had kind of washed away
so you had mostly pieces of metal you
know bigger pieces of metal and things
that you could see you know easier than
you could when it was all covered with
the you know the powder and stuff the
crew chief had died facedown in the
middle of the wreckage and the intense
heat of the burning aircraft had burned
him into a small charred piece of meat
his legs were completely gone from the
knees down his arms were gone from the
elbows out and something aluminum had
melted and burned through his head when
I touched what was left of his skull it
disintegrated into white powder as I was
trying to retrieve
his torso from the wreckage a broken
half at the lower back when it did some
of the liquid decay flew into my face
some of it all my lips I almost lost it
at this point it was almost impossible
to breathe and just as hard not to throw
up after a few minutes I was able to get
it on a poncho and move back into the
woodland wood line I had seen people
burned to death before but never to this
extent now that the body had been
recovered we had to find the jungle
penetrator and photograph it
the aviation unit did not believe the
cable had broken where I had said it had
they wanted photographic evidence before
we could do this however someone had to
be assigned to carry the body no one
wanted to in fact they wanted to leave
it behind I became somewhat forceful and
directed Wang to carry it this was part
of his punishment for the coke it took
only a few minutes to find and
photograph the jungle penetrator now it
was time to move to the other helicopter
blowing this one up was going to be the
highlight of the mission for me I always
enjoyed missions where I got to use
demolitions my only concern was where
were the bad guys we recovered the
demolitions leftover for three days ago
and carried them to the other crash site
I was really beginning to get the sixth
sense feeling that you have just before
everything breaks loose everything was
too quiet the helicopter was down in a
small ravine a very undefendable place
just as I communicated the decision to
move the five team members to the top of
the ravine bursts of ak-47 fire from
about three to four NVA began to hit all
around us the team returned fire as
quickly quickly as they moved to the top
of the ravine since there were only a
few of them I decided to stay with the
helicopter and plant the demolition
charges the bad guys shooting at us
turned out to be the point team for a
much larger group as I worked feverishly
to pack 40 pounds of c-4 into the
appropriate places the helicopter the
intensity of fire increased my hands
were beginning to bleed and blood was
dripping out of the ends of my fingers
of my gloves bullets were now ripping
through the floor and the side of the
aircraft some were even hitting the c4
as I packed it against the instrument
panel fortunately c4 requires a
detonation device like a blasting cap to
set it off
I felt like Houdini inside a chest
except instead of swords coming through
the sides
I had bullets as the battle intensified
i radioed for help
the fight was turning into a war and we
needed gunships now so there you are
stand in the middle is crashed
helicopter trying to pack c4 and to get
that thing completely destroyed did you
ever think when like something like that
hey I got a good idea once you guys just
drop a bomb on this thing
and by the way and also when somebody
tells me hey go search around for this
jungle penetrator with a cut cable and
take a picture of it I would had some
issues with that I had a lot of issues
for the whole thing they should have
told me the guy was there to start with
a pilot of that aircraft should have
said one of my guys is missing you know
he should never been left there to start
with
he never said there was another person
he said he had everybody he didn't that
guy was was out there we could have got
him out at the same time we got
everybody else out so it you know the
but the controversy is is brewing around
a lot of things between us and the
aviation you know commander over what's
going on but now I'm packing you know
the 40 pounds of c-4 in the air and I've
got a few hundred feet of det-cord too
that was left over so I got that big
roll of det cord in there with with the
c4 they're shooting hitting it you know
the thing that bothers me about that is
you know what that means it's coming too
close to me yeah and you know I've got
the blasting caps mm-hmm I'm thinking
once I stick the blasting caps in the c4
if a bullet hits one of those it's over
but at some point he got to do that had
to make the decision stick them in
ignite the fuses and try to get out how
long were the fuses
you know about three or four minutes not
long at all with the other guys up on
the ridge line still yeah and so you're
just honest another I'm down and Damned
dynamite solo mission
yeah they I needed them up there because
they had a higher angle of fire down on
the bad guys to keep them back and you
know I my plan was to go out there with
them and that having it in the gully and
having us back up on the high ground
like that provided some chill shielding
for us from the blast that was going to
happen I mean 40 pounds of c-4 and a
couple hundred feet of det-cord it makes
a pretty good display it goes off
they're not going to be anything left to
the helicopter no no once you pull that
time fuse by the way there better not be
anything that you can lazy lazy or no
exit from the scene no I had to get out
the decision was made when she popped
those who using not as the decisions
made you got to get on you cover that
here back to this document after a few
minutes another decision point it
arrived it was time to insert the
blasting caps and light the time fuse
the questions going through my mind war
when a bullet hit one of the caps and
detonate the c4 before I could get out
and move to a safe distance could I get
out without being hit I would be
completely exposed while climbing out if
I got out could I fully run expose could
I run fully exposed to the bank climate
15 feet and get to the team that's
another horrible thing because if you
put once you pull these time fuse if you
get wounded anywhere in that vicinity
you're done yeah it became obvious that
they knew I was in the helicopter and
we're moving in on me who is now or
never I inserted to blasting caps into
the c4 ignited the to time flew fuses
climbed out of the side of the
helicopter rolled to the ground low
crawl to the base of the bank and began
to climb like a madman
I'm sure it looked like a contest
between me and the enemy's bullets to
see which could dig into the ground the
most it only took a matter of seconds
but it seemed like an eternity my time
it might
really increase their volume of fire to
help cover me as I rolled up on top of
the Bank I looked back to see three to
five NVA
run up behind the helicopter if I had
waited a few more seconds they would
have had me several of the team members
looked quickly at me with the same
expression of disbelief that I had could
they really be hiding behind a
helicopter that had 40 pounds of c-4 and
200 feet of Denton that cord in it with
time-fuse burning were they going to try
and pull the fuses out and save the
helicopter it quickly came apparent that
they did not realize I had been setting
charges I could see the smoke from the
time fuses coming out of the helicopter
but the enemy were so engrossed in the
heat of battle that they did not realize
that they were about to become history
I signaled to the team that it was about
time for the explosion what happened
next was beyond words there was a
tremendous explosion producing a giant
black fireball followed by a shockwave
you could actually see the compressed
air moving out in a circular pattern
that literally dazed all of us there was
a momentary lull in the fire as it began
to rain metal pieces of metal Rock dirt
and tree limbs and the remains of the
NVA who'd been hiding behind the
helicopter the jungle was filled with
black smoke I had wanted a good
explosion and it was a good one but I
intended for it to be much further away
when it happened but I had intended to
be much further away when it happened
the enemy picked up quickly with a new
twist the end or sorry the enemy fire
picked up quickly with the new twist so
yeah that's pretty much you can't you
can't plan that one any better the enemy
you leave that helicopter with 40 pounds
of det cord 40 pounds of c4 and a bunch
of det cord which for those either don't
know det cord is just explosives in in a
string and so when it blows up it blows
up and it's actually pretty powerful
it's actually very powerful that cornice
so these guys were blown away by this by
this explosion and all they had to do
was see what was going on walk over and
caught the time fuse and they would have
been all right I don't know if they
still had time to get inside they had to
crawl somebody had to crawl inside to
pull it out okay
they could have pulled it out and tossed
it aside but you know when you're when
you're watching time-fuse burn it's not
like it all burns up to wherever it's
burning everything falls it's going down
through the middle through the tube yeah
and you don't know exactly where it is
so yeah they might grab it just as they
you know kiss account but we don't have
to worry about that worked out yeah
the enemy fire picked up quickly and
with the new twist they had moved a
machine gun position on the other side
of us that we are now in a crossfire we
were pinned down and couldn't move we
had to get rid of the machine gun or we
were all dead there was a small group of
rocks about 20 meters from our position
if I could get to those rocks I would be
able to call back directions to our m79
grenade gunner and we might knock out
the machine gun the problem was getting
across the 20 meters of open terrain
with fire coming from both sides without
getting hit they had also brought an RPG
and it fired a couple of those at us
time was running out I told the team to
cover me as I went across the ground
like a mole watching the mud being dug
up all around me the only way I could
explain not being hit was that God had
put a force field around me the enemy
had begun to shift their fire off of me
as I neared the rocks this seemed
strange but I was glad that it glad that
I made it I didn't think much about it
the rocks did not provide as much cover
as I had anticipated they would the
machine gun had to be dealt with quickly
I pulled myself over to the edge of the
bank and looked over and discovered why
the enemy shifted most of their fire off
of me
less than 3 feet for me was an NVA
crawling up the bank to get me I didn't
know whichever one of us had the biggest
look of shock on their face probably me
time began to move in slow motion in and
what was reality was 2 to 3 seconds
seemed like minutes in the next fraction
of a second he squeezed the trigger on
his ak-47 the first round just missed my
head by what must have been an inch or
two powder coming out of the barrel was
hitting me in the face as
bullets streamed out ak-47s have a
tendency to rise up when they are on
automatic so that the other bullets were
going over my head I squeezed off a
burst of six to eight rounds from a
distance of less than three feet they
all hit him in the face and the top of
his head cozened causing it to explode
sending debris all over me as his body
tumbled down the bank I could taste the
blood that had hit me in the mouth the
fire immediately shifted back on me and
I was hugging the ground so close that I
must have looked like an empty pair of
fatigues lying on the ground
nevertheless I felt an occasional bullet
hit my rucksack
fortunately the radio was not damaged a
green tracer ricocheted off a rock and
landed right in front of my face
I watched it lie there and burned as I
continued to fire at the enemy the
handguard on my 8 on my car 15 became so
hot I could no longer hold it I was
having to shoot one-handed I shouted
back directions to the m79 gunner his
first shot was high and off to the left
I continued to direct his fire until he
had hit a tree beside the machine gun -
sending shrapnel into the position the
two NVA were wounded and momentarily
stunned this gave me a chance to put 10
to 12 round bursts on them and silenced
the machine gun for good
oh man it was an exciting afternoon yeah
that's that's completely crazy I can't I
can't imagine sitting there as all this
machine gun fires happening that and the
tracer settles itself in front of your
face and you sit there and watch it burn
about this time - helicopter gunships
arrived I marked our position initially
with a flare gun and then with purple
smoke grenade after they had identified
our location I directed their minigun
40-millimeter grenade and rocket fire
into the enemy the gunships were
literally ripping the trees ground an
enemy apart even though we had already
killed a lot of enemy there were still
20 more shooting in us the gunship
spotted the enemy furthermore enemy
further down the ridge moving toward us
and fired rockets on them to slow their
progress I worked the air strikes in as
close as I could to our position and
eventually was able to suppress the
enemy fire enough to crawl back to the
team so far only one team member had any
serious wounds shrapnel from one of the
b40 rockets had hit him in the back it
was not life-threatening at the moment
but he using a lot of pain and bleeding
we were beginning to row run 'la run low
on ammunition and the enemy force was
increasing the time had come to break
contact with the enemy or die in place
yeah you you were going in order for
your car 15 to get that hot that you
could you put you were shooting a lot
yeah how many rounds did you go in with
I'm a normal on a SOG nation I usually
carrying around 50 magazines did you say
55 zero-five-zero magazines of course we
had the little ones yeah there was a
twenty rounds yeah I bet yeah because I
even though I was the leader I'd still
tended to engage the bad guys so you see
you're in there and what about for this
one where you know you're kind of a high
potential for contact I don't think we
had that many I don't remember exactly
how many I had you know maybe thirty or
so but you know a little less than I how
did you even load out 30 30 30 magazines
or 50 magazines I mean you can only fit
so many on your on your web gear you
wear the canteen canteen pouch you can
put 5 20 round magazine
and you know so I would I would carry
two of those at least on the bill and
then you know I'd put the others in the
rucksack so like on the left side I'd
have you know ten magazines you know
because you're gonna put the magazine
then when you left him the right side
I'd have one or two bags of grenades
because I could put usually five of
those in a canteen pouch and you're
gonna throw right handed you didn't want
to have to be rolling and turned I tried
not to put anything you know besides you
know the the med kit which was pretty
flat the gauze pads and things like that
my compass on the front so I could get
closer to the ground and then in the
rucksack I was loaded up wondering that
everything was so heavy and then you
know you had to have a couple of quarts
of water on the bill and sometimes more
in the rucksack you had two claymore
mines and the rucksack how many lame
horse would you usually carry I use like
here two and depending on the size of
the team we might everybody else might
have to but you know claymores a heavy
yeah would you would those be rigged the
ones rigged with like five second or 10
seconds yes we had diffusers depending
on what we wanted to do with them and
then you also had a rig for a perimeter
security that you can clock off you know
we carry a lot of stuff yeah yeah you
yeah it's to be in these kind of
firefights to shoot your weapon enough
that it's hot and to be sitting there
under that under that fire directed I
mean this is just this is these are
crazy things you can't barely even
capture how how well what your chances
are survival in a situation like this or
the chances are not good
let me put into that way whether with
the original m16 the handguard would get
hot but you know the regular troops
rarely you know fired on that much they
get warm with the car 15 it had a
different type of handguard front and
with the amount of barn that we were
doing and you know this thing was a
hundred and ten degrees to start with
and then you start you know putting it
was you know rounds through there as
fast as you can very quickly
it would get hot most Americans wore
gloves
you know I particularly had them on this
time because I didn't have any skin on
the inside of my hands a lot of the
muscle and meat was gone so and with and
we cut the fingertips out you know so we
had some dexterity to do things and I
would put a piece of canvas around the
handguard and that would just give me a
little extra protection until it got hot
and then you know just the one handed
thing having the small rope go through
the little site bracket up there and
hooked into the snap link on your
shoulder you could put pressure down on
that it made it easier to shoot
one-handed and be able to hold it down
you know because it was going to try to
come up on auto but you could do that it
was a little uncomfortable on that
fishing because of my hands but the good
thing about your hands is all of that
skin will grow right back he didn't take
it long it'll come back other places on
the body just didn't come back that fast
food all right so you guys are running
low on ammo and here we go back to this
document I signal the team to get ready
to move out and radio to the gunship
gunships what we were going to do as
they made their next run firing mini
guns 40 millimeter grenades and rockets
myself and two team members exposed
ourselves long enough to throw white
phosphorus grenades as far toward the
enemy as we could when they exploded
each productive produced a very dense 30
meter radius of white smoke and streams
of burning phosphorus the smoke didn't
stop the bullets but it did prevent them
from seeing our direction of escape we
quickly drugged the body and the wounded
team member into the thick jungle and
began slipping and sliding up the
I radio the gunships that we were clear
to make their next pass directly over
our old position marked with a red smoke
grenade estimating that the bad guys
would be there by then it was a good
move resulting in the gunships killing
several of them where we had been the
gunships continued to pound the area for
another 20 minutes sending thousands of
bullets hundreds of forty millimeter
grenades and dozens of rockets through
the jungle canopy onto them once again
the weather moved in on us very quickly
in the rain began to come down hard
before we were halfway up the mountain
the clouds were already covered the
clouds had already covered the ridgeline
we would not be distracted that day
tired and somewhat demoralized we
continue to climb toward the top of the
mountain we had at least temporarily
broken contact with the enemy eventually
we found a very dense rocky and steep
peak we thought we could defend the rain
continued the rest of the day and
throughout the night that's a morale
crusher yeah you're low on ammunition
you think you're making your your final
you know movement and then you're going
to get extracted and then the weather
comes in and you're shut down yeah it
didn't go over well with the team it had
a significant impact on the morale
because they really thought I really
thought that once we got up here we
would get extracted but not once the
weather rolled in then I knew man we're
gonna be here at least until tomorrow
and you know things just don't work out
as a leader in that position what what
is it important for you to do as a
leader as that miralles and it starts to
slip and part of part of what I was
doing
with them was congratulating them
because this is one of our first heavy
firefights as a team so pumping them up
how well they did how we discard all
those guys we've got the body that we
went down after
you know I said just trying to tell them
you really do a good job I said Wayne
don't ever think about bringing a soft
joint you know mission again that uh
that still okay so you give them like a
pep talk hey you did great but they got
to be looking at you hey hey thanks a
lot boss and now we're here and the
enemy that we just killed a bunch of
enemy what are they going to do they're
gonna come after us we've got to keep
the guard up pay attention you can't
dwell on what what's happened you know
the weather all clear when it clears in
the meantime we got a stay sharp and you
know we're in a good position if they
try to come up we'll take them out this
is like the ultimate form of of when
people get in competition of some kind
and they think they win and then it
turns out they don't yeah you know I got
a buddy named Tim Kennedy who's actually
a special force guy great guy and he was
actually a UFC fighter a mixed martial
arts fighter incredible fighter but he
had a he had a match against a guy and
the guy he was going against was an
Olympic champion guy a really tough guy
and Tim was beating him and I think it
was between the second and third round
the opponent didn't answer the bell so
he didn't come out to fight and then the
corner man there were some shenanigans
going on and all of a sudden with an
extra thirty seconds of rest or whatever
the guy stood up and ready to fight and
now Tim Kennedy who had just thought
he'd won because the guy didn't answer
the bell they go no no no it's not over
you got a fight and hearing him tell
that story to me you know he said it was
just this this situation right all of a
sudden he thought he would had one
thought the day was done raised his
hands in victory and then all of a
sudden oh you got a fight again and he
didn't you know he told me he's like I
didn't get back in the game and he ended
up losing that fight and that
unfortunately that fight would have put
him in the slot to be the the UFC
champion which he absolutely should have
been but it's it reminds me of this and
you as a leader
have to take these people in that moment
where they could let down their guard
they could get demoralized they could
give up and instead say no guess what
okay
hey good job we got to make it through
tonight we're not done yet and that
happens all the time
I mean Cunningham the first first gotta
to be an ace pilot in Vietnam when when
they shot down their v aircraft and then
something the mission was over they shot
down the that air that MIG and they turn
and go home and he and you know the
copilot they're patting each other on
the back man we're aces now we've done
this that was great and just going back
and forth they didn't hear the missile
alarm go off
fortunately they were almost back to the
coast doing the missile hill they had to
punch out they landed in the water and
you know got picked up out of the air
but they were celebrating so hard yeah
they'd like their guard down they
thought it was over it ain't over till
it's over that's right and in this
particular case it ain't over yet here
we go back to this document even though
the mission was supposed to been a five
hour mission I had made just everyone
just I made everyone bring two meals
just in case the team members had
grumbled about the extra weight but no
one was grumbling now nor did they
during the next day as the rain
continued we spent almost 48 hours on
that little peak constantly watching
listening and feeling for the enemy
before the weather cleared and we were
extracted needless to say everyone was
very excited to climb on board the
helicopter and head for home
even though the smell was terrible I
really look forward to seeing I really I
was really looking forward to some time
off to let my body and mind heal when we
arrived at the compound however I
discovered my team was scheduled to
begin preparing for a new mission the
next day on our would have to wait three
months later I was awarded the Air Medal
with the V device second award for
heroism during aerial combat for my
actions on May 4th 1969
the first trip I was also awarded the
Bronze Star medal with B device for
heroism in ground combat for my actions
on May 7 1969 the second trip and it was
worse when I got what would please tell
me what was worse than that because when
I and whoever wrote up you for a Bronze
Star for that no disrespect but I'd like
to slap that person right in the face
because that is ridiculous that entire
thing is ridiculous so when I got back
we had the aviation guy there with the
our Colonel again and he's saying you
probably want my helicopter I'm saying
that's what you told me to do
destroy the helicopter he said I didn't
tell you that you were not supposed to
destroy yeah
just put a thermite or something on on
the radios but not destroy the
helicopter I don't know what he thought
you do with it yeah but I said well that
Joker's in a million pieces out there
it's gone yeah next time do it yourself
I think quite go that far I might have
been thinking that I was not happy when
I heard that I wanted to hear you man
you did a great job
yeah why did you blow my helicopter up
Wow that's disconnected that's a very
disconnected person a very disconnected
leader unbelievable so that's that's
just completely crazy you did you get
wounded during that mission no just
banged up a little bit just back up a
little I mean it you know I it wasn't
uncommon to get hit with shrapnel or
something but you know I I got the
broken ribs and burned hands and all of
that you know with the first part of it
but you know
second part I just got skin up and stuff
so then so now what's the next let's see
that was in that was in 2 to 7 May and
then the next thing we got is a king be
down so one of the King B helicopters
goes down that wasn't a good day the
time you know I take RT Virginia and we
go on a mission and I I think that's the
one where it was the NVA division
regiment heading for hamburger hill we
were supposed to go find him and then
but bring airstrikes and things on try
to stop them it because hamburger hill
was a very political a battle that
happened the 101st I was trying to fight
their way up to the top of this mountain
taking all kinds of casualties and
everybody was questioning at the time
why do they need to go up got to take
the high ground it'll be a political
victory that as well as military as we
if we take it they were taking all kinds
of casualties the North Vietnamese had
this large unit that was coming and it
was going to crush that battalion and
you know so our mission was to go out
find it stop it don't let them get there
they had moved a lot further along than
we thought so we we do our little circle
and round thing and as we're coming in
on a short final they opened fire and I
hit the aircraft we lost power and you
know I'm sitting in the door and I'm
watching the ground come up and thinking
you know it's not good man we're going
to really smack in
and we did so hit the ground everything
went black and you know then I my eyes
come open and I'm laying there thinking
mm am i alive or dead and then I hear
the bullets cracking behind I'm thinking
I must be alive somebody's trying to
shoot me so I look around see what's
going on I get my guys were scattered
out on the ground too I drag them over
into a bomb crater that's there so we
had some protection they eventually got
the helicopter flying again oh wow we've
taken a lot of hits but he got it back
in here somehow was you the king be
pilots these were South Vietnamese
pilots South Vietnamese but yeah they
flew for us there
they're our guys yeah so you know we're
we're in the crater fighting they can't
get back in the ground fire is way too
heavy we're working the air strikes and
working the 81 ease we're hitting the
whole ridge line we're hitting the top
of the hill getting secondary explosions
up there you know because they'd already
moved a lot of ammunition and stuff up
on the hill so we're smoking it pretty
hard but I mean they can shoot right
across the top the bomb crater so it was
kind of hard to stick your head out
everybody's busted up I'm experiencing
you know a tremendous amount of pain and
I'm not quite sure where's this coming
from
I mean I'm hurting it's hard to breathe
all that kind of stuff but you know
we're getting a lot of kills they're
trying to crawl out there to us and then
eventually we suppress it far enough
that one helicopter is able to come in
and took everybody on the team except
for myself
and one guy so the two of us stayed
there in the bar now is that because the
crowd of the to many people is that
because they're a tactical reason to do
that
in this case I wanted somebody else with
me and and that we were loading the
aircraft down we're really putting too
much weight on it so you the fear was if
you if you both if everyone got on that
the King be it wouldn't be able to take
off it would go down so - you're gonna
stay yeah go you know it's a question
kind of like we talked about before
sometimes you have to the way to the
good of the many against the one and you
know for us the the best solution was
for us not to get on the helicopter we
would stay there if we got out we got
out we didn't we didn't but the rest of
the team you know would survive so so
they went away we're still you know
doing a lot of shooting working gunships
and stuff and then I just got a little
irritated and I thought I need to go get
one of them I think what I'm gonna do is
just crawl out there because there I
know they were crawling around that
thing in the grass I'm gonna crawl that
didn't get one of these dealers mm-hmm
meaning you're gonna go and capture
alive the enemy so you know cuz because
you're writing now you have two people
two of you you're injured somehow you
don't really know what it is you're in a
bomb crater you're surrounded by an NVA
division and you think now's a good time
to go over to captures of what if I
ain't gonna get somebody I mean this
might be my last chance
Jack I'm gonna snatch one of those
jokers up because if we can take him
back I mean he give a lot of Intel about
where they are what they're doing and
everything so I start crawling out there
in the grass yeah and the grass is about
that but two and a half three feet high
and I am crawling around out there and I
can hear him you know because they're
shooting he's still shooting down at the
the bomb crater they haven't realized
that I've crawled out there with him and
I can hear this one up in front of me
and I'm crawling up there and you know
if I can get the timing right so that he
doesn't see me you know immediately then
you know I can probably wound him
dragging back in and you know he'll be
ours it just didn't go well when we had
to encounter so I more than wounded him
no yeah so I didn't have a prisoner
shoot at him or did you stab him yeah I
shot him yeah I mean there are times to
use a knife but sometimes you need to do
it quick and you know he's got buddies
you know you can only reach so far with
a knife there but with that car 15 you
know he's way out there and tap somebody
yeah so I decided to go back in because
I just didn't have any strength and I
wasn't sure what what was going on so I
got back in eventually well you suppress
the fire enough that they were able to
come back in and get the two of us and
went went back to the launch site and
they said you know that was good but
there's still a ton of them out here and
I need you to go back in tomorrow
morning so take the team back you know
I'm sorry
replaced some team members and why'd you
replace team members because some of
them were injured a helicopter crashed
in so and what about you you're back and
whatever I got whether he's I got with
him medics and they drug me up and they
said you know with an impact that hard
you know you're bound to have some you
know some bruises and whatever and
that's it men this is not bruises I mean
it's hard to breathe when I live but
anyway they said we really need you to
back out here tomorrow morning I mean
this is critical okay I'm gonna go do it
so we go back in same the same insertion
point no we we moved over to different
location you know a few clicks away from
that first one and went in and right
iceberg got on the ground and we started
in into the jungle we made contact so
all of a sudden we were in heavy contact
there and trying to suppress that fire
working the gunships and things that we
had with us
got it suppressed enough that we were
able to get again all with me and one of
the guys out on strings and lifted them
out so the two of us were still there
still working the air strikes and we
were in a better position at this point
to really hit the main body of the force
and you know we had that big stick with
us and we were hammering those guys
literally thousands of them were killed
you know that morning I mean we we
pretty much decimated you know that
force they were you in an elevated
position yeah yeah so we were up pretty
close to the top of a mountain and we
could see him in the valley we could see
him on the ridge line coming up to where
we were we could see him on the ridge
line where we did they know where you
were I yeah I mean from the fire that
was going on they knew we were up there
but they couldn't get up there to us
except for the ones that were already
there because you know now we had a big
enough air support team with us out
there to just smoke them we had this
Bad's you know that anyone ease we had
they'll force and gunships and just
rotating those things in I mean they
were stacked out here waiting on their
turn to come in and go after him where
we were you know I could see him and we
had you know pretty significant contact
right there
and where we were directly on us and for
some reason it just seemed like a good
idea to take one of them back with us oh
so you got the notion again that you're
gonna try and capture so I thought you
know it's a different terrain I need to
get one of them so I I crawled out here
you know wood covering fire from a
little guy encountered the guy and you
know I didn't have the strength to
manhandle I wounded him but I was
hurting so bad I just didn't have the
strength
I mean I under normal conditions I could
have brought him back but I was in too
much pain so you know I had to you know
let him go to happy hunting ground and
wherever you know and crawl back and
later on that day myself and the other
guy were able to come out on the strings
and and then they really hammered to
place there how long were you on the
ground for on that one most of the day
it was a long time and you know when we
got back they I said you know yeah I
think there's something wrong with you
said yeah I think so
by the way the NVA that that element of
NVA of thousands and thousands of NVA
did they ever make it a hamburger hill
so so that's why the that's why I'm you
know 101st was not wiped out they did
finally make it to the top and once they
got up there and said you know we're the
king of the hill they were told okay
come on back down when that kind of
stuff was going on what did you guys
would was that you know we we look back
armchair quarterback and say oh you know
what what were they thinking what were
you guys thinking when you guys hear
that would hear about that would you
think what the hell is the leadership
doing what are we doing I mean why would
you do that why would you sacrifice that
many lives and I forgot now the exact
number but it was a lot of Americans
kill trying to get the top of that hill
just to turn around and walk back down
and and I know it wasn't just that it
were a big political move and everything
but it's just my opinion that I don't
think it was worth losing people like
that if you kind of turn around and go
back down right now did you guys think
about that you talk about that did you
guys look at each other and say what the
hell are we doing why would we make this
sometimes sometimes when we would get
back you know the team members setting
that you know the American members
sitting around sometimes we would say
man did you see what here what happened
and questioning you know some of the
political things that were going on
because now it's 19
69 yeah so the this is like the height
of the American anti-war movement right
now this is like Woodstock's come in and
all that stuff yeah are you guys hearing
any of that we are hearing some about
the protests but you know we didn't get
to see I mean we didn't have TVs and
stuff like that we didn't we didn't see
what was going on if you got a hold of
an army times you might see something in
there but a lot of stuff was held back
because they you know didn't want us
being exposed to it but you knew and you
had heard from people who were coming in
more recently things that they had seen
you knew that you were likely to be spit
on and the airport or on the street if
you were in uniform and it was what are
you thinking about that I mean if are
you just can you even fathom that well I
wasn't happy about it and whether a lot
of hijackings of planes going on at that
time too so not not by protesters but by
different people hijacking them to fly
to different countries and you know one
of my thoughts was this browning
hi-power nine-millimeter that I took off
of a NVA I'm carrying that with me on
the plane my plane is not going to be
hijacked it would be the hijackers worst
nightmare to try to stop my plane so I
carried it with me and I had it when I
went through the airport I did yet spit
out I got called baby killer you know
all kinds of things like that you know
from various groups in the airport it
was not the Welcome Home kind of thing
that you see today although we don't I
don't think we do a very good job today
we do a lot better than we did
mm yeah I wasn't happy about what was
going on so you you were about to say
before I cut you off you're about to say
that you get back and now they're you're
saying hey there's something actually I
think there's actually something wrong
with me yeah
they decided that I they decided at the
time that I had severely bruised my my
back and maybe some vertebrae and I
think I broke another couple of ribs I
don't remember right now but I think
there's a couple of ribs broken too and
you know beat up cut up but then it was
determined later that I had fractured my
spine and a couple of vertebrae and they
just couldn't believe that I actually
went on a mission like that and was able
to do you know what we did so what'd
they give you a couple days downtime and
some motrin
oh the family really promised that and
then they said yeah I got a few days
downtime after that but yeah a motrin
like it was candy and that it was okay
you got eventually you know by the time
the next mission came around yeah you go
and it was you you have a note in here
about the the powa is that is that after
you got home no this is still I'm still
over there okay so we got Intel got
Intel all of a sudden that said there
was a small group 10 to 15 American POWs
that were being moved north and the
Intel said we know where they are so
they said we need to get them so that
became the mission but it was going to
be intense combat kind of mission so
what we did was we created a spike team
so buddy of mine Bruce longboard and I
would do that sometimes we would put our
two teams together
so we'd have about 20 or so people to
take out there we took a medic with us
this time we were
we were loaded for bear to machine guys
all is a you know extra ammo and
everything and our mission was to go out
and find him and get him back so we went
to the launch site with we were supposed
to launch and the next day there was a
hatchet force that was there too
that had a mission to go I don't know
what their mission was but they were
going somewhere and we had a team Dennis
Neal and Michael Browns team was on the
ground they had finished their mission
they moved back to an extraction LZ they
had called for extraction and then all
of a sudden they called a prayer fire
emergency that they were being overrun
and then we lost contact with with the
radio contact with the team one of the
aircraft using one of the aircraft out
in the area heard a transmission on the
little URT radio that just operated on
the guard frequency they picked up what
they thought was an American voice
saying you know somebody help me help me
for God's sake somebody help me
I heard that horse and that was all we
heard and so every may rethink the
launch site stopped what guys now it's a
prairie fire and we've got to go get
Dennis's team you know and that was a
situation where I didn't have a two day
or an hour coming out but I'm looking at
the aircraft that's about to go out to
try to bring them back and I'm thinking
I probably should get on that aircraft
you know I think I should go with them
and now I think in case I've got a
leader lead my own mission to get POWs
you know in a couple of hours I've got
to go do that I can't jump on you know
this aircraft and fly out there
the
that's not gonna work so I didn't go
they went out into the area they saw
some movement they saw you know what
they thought were good guys they dropped
the Maguire ease down and as they were
lifting off three of them pull tight and
then one of them shot loose and they
came on up they had two indigenous
personnel on the Makai rigs and you know
or the the crew chief said he thought he
saw an American on that third one
that popped loose that he thought an
American had gotten in there and fell
out as they were you know pulling
attention up but they were receiving
some ways fire you know they couldn't go
back in there so they brought the two
survivors from the team back to the
launch site did a quick debriefing from
them they said everybody else is dead
they launched the hatchet force to go in
as a bright like team they changed their
mission to bright light and decided to
put them out there because they were you
know so many bad guys in the area but
they inserted them a couple of thousand
meters away from from you know where the
extraction site was they were pinned
down on the LZ never never moved
anywhere they just got in another tree
line and that was as far as they could
go
so once that started happening and they
saw they couldn't go anywhere then they
came to me and said you know your
missions changed and you were now the
bright light team yeah so got all my
guys together and said okay we're going
bright light the other mission we'll do
later so then you know they and we we
planned the mission right quick and they
inserted us you know the whole spike
team so I mean that's five aircraft
going in they said you know it's a
really hot area so we're gonna we'll
prep the LZ but we have to be careful
because we don't know where the other
team members are that might be out there
so
can't just hammer the whole area we can
only prep it right around the LZ so they
went out you know the gun shops ahead of
us they prep the LZ and you know I'm
listening on the headset and it's not
sounding good and you know I knew we
were going to get hammered because they
were going to open up all I said saying
is we got close and I was in the lead
ship and as we started in you know the
bullets had come in everywhere here the
aircraft's taking hits the ones behind
me have taken hits but we went on in got
on the ground got my first load in the
tree line brought into the rest of the
guys one ship at the time working air
strikes you know right around us at
suppress the fire as much as we could so
we spent until the next afternoon mostly
fighting looking for Dennis's team
trying to find any survivors that we
could so it was a long night and they
were firing mortars over at the hatchet
force we could hear him from back up
behind us I mean I would call them and
say you know rounds on the way because
I'd hear him drop it into you and douche
you know and I just tell him you know
you got incoming and get everybody down
but we couldn't get to where the mortars
were because they had you know too many
people around us when he got daylight
we're still looking for more looking for
Dennis Moore was discovered we were in
the middle of a bunker complex bunkers
were all around us and that's why one
reason that the LZ prep didn't have much
of the fact they were in their bunkers
and so anyway we brought in a lot of air
support eventually got out
Dennis's team was never found and the
the two survivors there's no doubt in my
mind that they gave us the wrong
location
we're where the team was when it was
overrun I don't I don't think they did
it intentionally I think it was
distressed I think it was being chased
trying to survive I think they lost
track with how far they moved to get to
where they were picked up from because
otherwise you would have found something
we would have found something now you
can go out there and you can find people
who've written all kinds of things about
Dennis's mission and that nothing you
know what was evidence was found and
things like that I was there I was the
guy on the ground you know I searched
that area I know what was there and you
know Dennis was my roommate so we were
you know we were already very close and
you know so I had that personal stake
and finding his team no we just didn't
make it so we came back so our mission
for the PW is where it was postponed and
we went back down I started replanting
that mission again but you know because
according to Intel they had moved more
so we had to pick a new site to go into
and kind of think through it a little
differently and it turned out to be one
probably one of the most interesting
missions that I had maybe one of the
most unique and saw because of a couple
of things that happen
well like what you know it's it's it's
really interesting that if anyone listen
to this podcast we've we I had on a one
of the one of the guys I've had on the
podcast was a guy named Colonel William
reader and he was a helicopter pilot
that was shot down two times and the
second time he was shot down he was
captured and he was one of those folks
that was being moved from South Vietnam
to the north which was actually the
worst possible thing to have happening
and guys died on those tracks and you
know this was this was them the the
stereotypical image that you get of the
Vietnam prisoner of or in the jungle
that's what these guys were going
through so the guys in the Hanoi Hilton
that were at least they were identified
people knew that they were there etc
these guys in the jungle they were just
getting you know every horrible thing
that could possibly happen happen to
those guys so when you talk about the
fact that you knew you know you had
Intel this is the type of person that
I'm thinking that you're going to save
you know this is someone like Colonel
William reader who you know the stories
that he told about being captured and
you know at one point he was in a two
foot tall bamboo cage his legs are
shackled he's in the middle of the
jungle
he hasn't eaten and he's trying to get
some sleep but he can't sleep because
the rats are knowing at the wounds in
his legs so that's the when you say hey
you got an opportunity to go capture
these these these guys that's what I'm
thinking about and you're doing all this
just on top of you know losing your
friend your brother Dennis Neill who
completely you know disappears
so what changed about what changed about
the mission when what what did it
started what made it so well having we
were going into a different location
different route but other net the
beginning was basically the way it was
supposed to go when it when we got
canceled before we go we go in
relatively uneventful and we get on the
LZ and you know it's the big team so
Bruce and I of our teams together and
it's a big one
and we start moving up the ridge line it
was kind of a late insertion not last
light but kind of late we start up the
ridge line we get a few hundred meters
up there and then we stop you know for
the night you know because you got a big
group now it takes longer to get
everybody in position and get set up get
all the claymores hot get everything the
way you know what you need it so and so
now we have a larger parameter I am in
the center of it and Bruce is you know
close to me but I know where he is and
what was interesting was you know it got
dark and the weather is starting to get
bad but it's dark and you can't see your
hand in front of your face and I'm
leaning against the tree my rucksack
behind me you know my car 15 across my
lap like I normally do and I'm just
about asleep and I hear a twig break and
my eyes open and I'm thinking wow did I
just hear a twig break and then I hear
another one and I'm saying to myself
that's directly in front of me there's
somebody in front of me that's moving in
this direction and so now I'm listening
and I'm saying you know somebody is
coming directly at me and I'm thinking
how did he get through the perimeter I
mean we're not spaced very far apart at
all
hey in the world could this guy have
walked through our perimeter maybe he's
on the inside now and he's coming you
know straight at me and so I'm playing
all those thoughts in my mind and he's
getting closer and now I've got my
adrenaline going I got my super senses
working and even though it's so dark I
can't see anything I can visualize him
in front of me I can literally see a
black silhouette in my mind because I'm
tracking the sound I can hear him
breathing and he's coming right at me
and I'm thinking this is not gonna be
good this guy it's gonna walk right into
me
and so I've got to make a decision you
know if I just shoot him right now
it's gonna light me up you know like a
neon sign and all these buddies are
gonna open up I've got to do something
he's about to step on me so I've got
this like just switch on the full I got
my weapon in the hand and I'm tracking
mentally this silhouette and when it
gets in my mind where he's within reach
my plan was I'm gonna reach out and grab
ahold of him I'm gonna cram the barrel
of the car 15 in there his head and I'm
gonna pull him he'll be off balance I'll
pulling and bring him down to the ground
if he fires his weapon if he yells if he
makes any kind of sound I'm just gonna
put a three or four round burst into his
head and of course I don't light me up
and everybody'll you know start shooting
at me you know but I can't let him be in
there so when he got within and range I
reached up I grabbed him it does the
same instant
the gun hit him in the side the head cut
a big gash in his head I pulled him down
he hasn't said a word I jerked him right
down to the ground and the gun is there
and I'm saying now what am I gonna do
I mean I've got him but what am I gonna
do with him and all of a sudden I hear
him whisper
Charlie Charlie his head looked out
lieutenant lights lights what lights
lights and I realize we had a Vietnamese
captain with us Jimmy's army captain and
he had seen something and he was coming
to tell me you know what does he you
know he wasn't used to going out with us
and he was coming to tell me I've got
him down on the ground now with a gun
stuck halfway through his head and he's
saying lights and lights and and I look
up and I'm looking up the ridge up
toward the top of the mountain and all
the way from the top of the mountain
about halfway down the ridge are just
lights I thought you know there might be
flashlights but I think there was some
kind of a lantern and there was just a
stream of people coming down the
mountains you know so I led him up
I look back down the ridge and there's a
stream of lights as far as I can see
down the ridge
coming up the guy that's monitoring
radio right then says sir you need to
hear this he hands me the handset and I
respond and what I hear is you are now a
prairie fire emergency this is coming
from Sonic headquarters down in and
Saigon being relayed to tell us that we
are prairie fire emergency and I'm
thinking I didn't know that but I mean
you know I'm looking now and seeing all
these lights and I'm thinking you know I
where we probably are and we're carrying
KY 38 all right we have the most secure
tactical radio is that there is the kind
that you have to set that gun with about
20 manual settings on the punch in the
crypto code you have to have all the
frequencies you have to have all the
settings and then the guy monitoring
radio it says it's all you need to hear
this nothing know what these guys are
coming from everywhere and he's got
something else he wants me to listen to
now you pick up the handset and I'm
thinking what do I hear it's music I'm
hearing music coming over the handset
and then I hear this female NVA
whatever start talking and it dawns on
me all of a sudden there's this funeral
music this is the obituary music this is
the what I used to hear when I was
little on my grandmother's radio every
day you know at lunch they do the news
but then they would do the obituaries
for the people you know in that county
or whatever that had had died and they'd
read off your name and all the stuff and
they'd have this music in the background
and this female is reading off our
obituaries that we were killed in action
that day and she reads my name off as
dick Thompson and I'm thinking there's
only one person on this side of the
world who knows me as dick that has any
clue that that's my name you know you
know that was Bardwell and you you know
barge well with someplace nobody had him
and she reads my name off his dick
Thompson reads off the name
remember that we had on the team all of
us is being killed in action that day on
the secure encrypted radio Saigon is
listening to this and thinking what is
going on and I'm thinking what he's
going this isn't making me you know a
little nervous how did you know my name
how did they get on this frequency and
you know and then that goes away so it's
kind of got my attention now the bad
guys are coming so you start you know
talking back and forth you know with
they've got a cubby out in the area now
so we start talking about you know what
our options for getting us out of here
because the weather's not that good
there are tons of North Vietnamese all
around us I got this one woman who had
just told us all that we were killed
today and read our obituaries
I should get our names so everyone is in
shock and confused about you know what's
what's going on how did they know
exactly where we were and they're coming
out at us the weather is starting to
roll in and you know the clouds are
slowly starting to come down on the
mountains so now I'm thinking I mean
we're not going to be a get air support
they can't get aircraft in to extract us
and I'm having this conversation now
we'd cover you about I need some options
because these these guys are gonna be
here pretty soon and you know it's not
going to be pleasant
I mean we're loaded for bear but not for
that many people not to be trapped in
between them so finally they said you
know one option might be combat Scot
spots
well that's ELF force coming out with
500-pound bombs and you know you give
them a coordinate two or three thousand
meters away from you they're flying by
radar and being vectored by radar toward
those coordinates
and then when the radar says you're at
the right place to release the bomb you
release you know a bomb and you see
where it hits so this is because it's a
nighttime it's in right now is night
well this night plus now the clouds are
down on the mountain so he can I mean he
can even see the mountain that we're on
over the ridge line sorry what was that
patient of that technique called combat
sky spot combat sky spot it's okay so
it's a technique that's not used very
often because it's not very accurate
right and you know only because this was
an emergency situation they you and
approve it and you know they said you
you need to give us a set of coordinates
that's you know two or three thousand
meters away to start with Lading put one
bomb out there and let's see where it
hits and then we'll start to adjust so I
said that's all we got let's do it so it
didn't take long to there's an l4 on the
area and and I actually you know using
my emergency radio I was able to talk
you know directly to to the l4 which you
know you can't no one we do and you know
he's only the bombs away it's gonna be
impact about twenty seconds you guys get
you head down I'm not sure it's kind of
yet I'm thinking that's nice to know
so it goes off and you know it's a lot
closer than you know 3,000 meters so I'm
thinking I'm really glad I firstly don't
out the Airways anyone it really wasn't
on the was an online with a ridge anyway
kind of over the ridge and down into the
valley but at least I knew where
approximately were hit so I could start
to adjust him some now so we started
messing with that with that irritated
the North Vietnamese they were not happy
that somebody was out there trying to
drop a bomb on
so we we overheard radio transmissions
saying shoot them in the legs take all
their Americans prisoner and we got a
message coming out from Saigon
they were intercepting North Vietnamese
transmissions and said they plan to
capture you and they're going to try to
wound you and take you okay then we got
to get these Scott spots working for us
here get them in closer and the bad guys
are getting closer and closer and so I
start working them down and you know I'm
coming behind a tree and one of the
bombs goes off and a piece of shrapnel
you know two and a half inches or so in
diameter comes out across the top of my
head goes into the tree right in front I
mean it just cuts you know a line across
the top of my head is it's going into
the tree and I'm thinking I was close I
mean I was pretty close so you know I
was behind a tree for a little while
once he cooled down a little bit I
popped it out and I put it in my pocket
I still have it at home somewhere I
wanted to bring it just a joy to you but
you know so that creased the top of my
head got my attention now you know
they're serious about doing something
eventually when we we do some gun
battles and stuff and that's going on is
it like yet no but it's getting close
when it when it finally did get light
there was a marine squadron that came a
helicopter squadron that came out and
with gunships and I guess the the leader
came over close to where the ridge line
was and we just received so much ground
firing stuff from it he told the rest of
these guys back off we're not going in
there there's too much ground fire
and then all of a sudden I'm I get a
call from one of the gunship pilots and
he says hey I'm coming no don't come in
here you try to fly off that Ridge
you're gonna have to go solo
you kind of flower on the treetops it
barely moving you're gonna have to
almost be hovering they're gonna knock
you down don't come in here
we'll find a way don't come up here you
say I'm coming so this was a helo yeah
helicopter gunship Marine Corps
helicopter gunship so it went but if you
mean I could hear him coming in a few
minutes and then I heard him I forgot
his name
now Eagle Claw something Mayday Mayday
Mayday we're hit and you know we're
going down and you know so I talked to
him a little more and then he said he
sent out another Mayday and said you
know we're on fire going down I'm gonna
try to make it to the river so this is
not good so and he actually he made it
to the river and it was kind of a deep
swell flowing river went in sideways the
pilot got out that door gunner on that
side got out and the two of them got out
the crew chief on the on the side that
went and went in first and the copilot
didn't get out one of the I mean the guy
the door gunner he got out was a good
swimmer and stuff so he jumped into the
water and swam over there and went down
you know to try to get him the other
gunner got out but the pilot couldn't
get out and never saw the that we're
gonna her again he never came back up so
they lost those I was two guys too many
bad guys in that area they couldn't go
in to try to you know extract the two
guys that didn't come up but they did
get the the pilot and
and there's a door gunner out and so
that wasn't a good scene so how far away
was that from you from your little they
their impact with the river was probably
3,000 meters okay
so this is all in the vicinity of you
yeah it's all right around me so I know
they go in and then you know we have a
we have a battle and it's not looking
good there's too many of them and we
have no place to go so it eventually
gets to the point where I'm talking back
to Covey talking to the elf fours
do you have any cluster bomb units got
any CPU on board and he said they did I
said put it on my position and you know
I don't know if you seen cluster bomb
units but it's like it's a big container
and it's full small bomblets at about
the size of a grapefruit or a little
bigger so it drops out about the
canister comes open and you know it just
rains about 200 of those things down on
you so so how close so the enemy was all
right there right there I mean I'm
already at a point I mean for you to be
calling I'm looking around to your
position that means you're about to be
overrun I'm looking around saying man is
this the last thing I said what time of
day is it though it's mid-morning
someone's memory so you guys have been
in heavy contact the entire morning the
enemy is closing in on your position
they're making progress obviously
because now you're getting to a point
because we can't go up or down I mean in
the side is the size of the ridge or
very steep so we can't go down the ridge
on the sides and they're coming in and
I'm thinking how long will I be able to
keep pulling the trigger I mean once I
start getting hit did you guys already
blow your claymores your parameter
claymores claymores are gone come in
they're coming
and you had 20 guys in this gentleman
about yeah
so the parameter we're in that's I mean
it's bigger than this a little bigger
than this room
so we're acting like 15 by 15 feet it's
it's a fairly small parameter and you
guys are surrounded by and you know the
you know thousand in the thousands of
hardened NVA so regulars yeah and
they're coming and you know I tell a
tell the pilot make you first run put it
on us if you don't have any come back on
a radio and then make your next pass and
just level everything on this Ridge
because that means we're not here yeah
so he he told us heads down who's coming
in and it rains all these things down
and we had seven of them the land either
inside the perimeter or right on the
edge of the perimeter none of them went
off none of them exploded but they were
exploding all around us you know and you
could hear the screams and all the stuff
because some of them were going off in
the trees shrapnel was going everywhere
and it broke broke their attack yeah so
I told him put another one on the side
yeah
that's working you can back off a little
bit now so that's just divine
intervention yeah for there to be seven
of those cluster bombs that land inside
your perimeter and none of them go off I
mean that just doesn't happen that's the
oh you might have one or two of them
that go off somewhere but not all the
ones that are right there and all the
other ones do go on the others do you go
off I mean I don't know that there was
something out there appears that they
all went off so they backed off things
calm down a little bit so I had to Bruce
send some of his people to look for a
way down the rich could we could we go
down somehow so a team went out and I
got a call back saying we just found the
remains of another SOG team
down on the side of the ridge ship and
there's you know if there's one one body
here in gingiva body what do you want me
to do I said well we need to identify
who the person is so without going into
detail I just told him take the
appropriate action so he could be
identified and bring you know that back
to each other team so and then we
finally get some gunships working now
because the weather's starting to lift
up we've got I mean we've been bombing
you know quite a bit during the night so
we start working down toward the LZ that
we can't come in on so we're going to
try to get an extraction there ran into
a small ambush but you know that didn't
last long so we were able to keep going
got down to the to the LZ and we're
looking around you know looking for bad
guys but what I see is the tail fin
sticking up out of the ground couple
feet to the 500-pound bomb sticking in
the LZ unexploded so now we're thinking
are we gonna bring a helicopter in here
with that bomb setting they're
unexploded so we told cubby this is
what's going on we really like to get
out of here because they're coming back
and so we have some dialogue and they
decided okay we're gonna do the
extraction cuz it's gonna take five
aircraft to get us out so we started
rotating them in and with my team it's
going to be the last you know team out
so we've got two machineguns placing
fire and you know how to suppress the
fire the gunship sort of suppressing
fire and rotating those chips in and we
had so many gunships and they one he's
you know on standby out there and just
waiting on their turn to come in it was
unreal but eventually I think it was
around 1700 you know we got out so
started at 2100
the day before and you know 1700 we
finally got it extracted and headed back
but we didn't you know get to go after
the their prisoners so then the question
start how could they know who was on a
team how could they have the frequencies
they had to have a KY 38 where did they
get that so it was I mean in I to my
knowledge those questions were never
answered if they were answered you know
we never found out how they managed to
do that you know there was about about a
two-week delay between the time that we
did the bright light mission for
Dennis's team God and us coming back
right
so I mean the mission had already been
planned and I had taken a couple of
weeks and then we get delayed a couple
of weeks so there was a leak somewhere
had to be a leak in our compound so the
information got out and I think when you
were talking to tilt he was saying you
know in late 69 and going into 70 whole
teams are just disappearing
I mean information was getting out
somehow I mean they were getting smarter
but the information was getting out and
we're losing teams so that was a little
unique because he doesn't know where to
get your obituary I mean and no and
there was one girl we don't normally get
at one point there we found out actually
we got back we found that there was a
point during the during the mission
there where they had actually listed us
as m.i.a
because all the radio traffic they were
picking out from the North Vietnamese so
they had us mmm that we really wasn't
there now and all this bombing and stuff
that was going on we wasn't there
did any no did anyone get wounded during
that yeah straps wrapping stuff there
was no one no one was killed but you
know we trapped no I got the top of my
head okay
and you got that qualification of
calling a cluster bomb in on your
position and she's a pretty rare one to
walk away from yeah and you know so I
guess today you know in this day when I
hear people saying let's ban cluster
bombs we don't want to use cluster bombs
I'm thinking man I'm glad that thing was
around at least one time yeah that's
sort of the you know that's like the I
don't always say the ultimate horrible
situation it doesn't get any worse than
when you are calling for air strikes on
your position that's that's the absolute
that's that that's the last thing you do
right you know that's when you say we're
gonna be over on we're probably gonna
die this is our last-ditch effort this
is the ultimate of all Hail Marys this
is it call for fire on our position and
that's what you did him by the grace of
God those Browns that hit inside your
perimeter that's the only way you can
explain it I'm telling ya and give me
one other so I'm trying to get the last
helicopter loaded and get my guys on it
and this one's doing the sound screens
too but I'm standing right next to the
helicopter I'm putting people on and I
hear a voice that says drop a loud voice
that says drop without hesitation I just
collapse to my knees and as I did about
a 10 round burst of machine-gun rounds
hit the side of the chopper right where
my head was
I mean a fraction of a second later you
know I would have been decap and you
know decapitated I mean there were
things like that happening you know
throughout and you think where did this
come from why how's all this happening
that's beyond the coincidence yeah it is
and you know it was a definitely an
interesting mission I just you know very
upset that you know we didn't get to go
after the POWs but yeah
what's a prairie fire what is it called
prairie fire
prairie fire to the the area of
operations is they would call prairie
and and then the prairie fire emergency
was when there was a bad situation to
where these guys need to get extracted
that's the best of prairie fire
emergency they can afford for us to be
captured or discovered so whatever it
took to make sure that we were not and
and if you read the SOG material you'll
read about here about that you know
sometimes the team it's rumoured Wrigley
just that sometimes a b-52 strike was
put on teams that disappeared to make
sure there were no survivors I've been
I've done bombers assessment damages I
have to be fifty team strikes though
never had one put on me and you know
this would have been a good time for him
to put one out there if they were going
to do that but I I don't know that
that's true you know that you had
volunteered to go on a mission where you
can't under any circumstances be taken
alive so you have it you have another
mission highlighted where it just says
prisoner snatch 22 caliber pistol with
silencer
did you ever get your prisoner I never
got one alive my lion at what point did
your nickname or your code name turn to
Terminator I'm thinking it might have
had something to do with this yeah it
was it was actually after SOG on some
other things I was doing it was you know
I had commanders you know starting with
we dig Meadows that started this thing
about you know you're the most
relentless person I have ever seen I
you're the last person in the world I
want to have coming after me because you
just want to stop
and you know I had other commanders you
know after that saying the same thing
and after you know Terminator movie came
out and oh they they named that movie
after you yeah god but then you know the
name all of a sudden was prominent and
you know so you know they said you're
your name's really you know Terminator
so I kind of hung onto that one I use it
as a race name when I do Ironman
competitions and stuff and uh I had a
good conversation when I was talking to
tilt and he would he went through a lot
of the scenarios that he described was
he was talking about the dogs that would
be coming after him oh yeah and you know
I asked tilt I said do you like dogs he
says I hate dogs and he said it without
a moment of hesitation I said what do
you think of dogs I said I hate dogs and
of course he also said his wife likes
dogs and therefore they have dogs but
are you uh are you scarred from from
dogs as well no even though I do have a
robotic dog I've had a lot of dogs you
know across the years but you can deal
with dogs I mean they were they tend to
give your position away sometimes but
you know the 22 pistol with a silencer
is still going to make some noise but
it's the dog if the dog gets far enough
away from the group you know you can
take him out you know with one of those
you can put out CS powder you know on
the trail and that really screws their
smell up when they sniff that so there
are ways to deal with dogs but it yeah
it scares you a little bit when you
realize they're coming after you with
dogs
I prefer trackers because I know how to
get them I don't I don't miss trackers
they will step on one of my minds the
Hardys trackers to get rid of when they
put three of them out there at different
locations with a couple of pieces of
bamboo and they'll clack the bamboo over
here and you'll hear that and you say
we're not going that way so we start to
turn this way and if you go too far
you'll hear clacking over on this side
though so they're actually channeling
their channel you right in into an
ambush you know that it's going to
happen so it's hard to put out toque
whoppers or something for those guys
because they're so far away from you and
you don't know where they're gonna walk
he can't get to him so you know that
makes it more interesting you can't get
away because you know they're hurting
you right what was the deal with the the
note you have in here about the 22 the
hush puppy 22 with the silencer and the
and the prisoner snatch was that just
another failed prisoners match well it
was another technique yeah I I had
trouble keeping them alive but with the
22 we used a similar scenario as the
ambush we were talking about where I had
a I shot 222 I would shoot the guy in
the thigh and it was it would sting
enough it would cause them to drop their
hands from their weapon and then topper
you know we'd take him down I'd hit the
morphine in him and you know that was
the plan
you know I hit the femoral artery one
time with the 22 up all the way I mean
the whole Lake Deere and I hit this
David artery you know so the guy bled to
death I mean just just little accidents
like that that gotten away and I didn't
have but one of the other team said they
had one and he was alive they were
coming out on strings and one of the
little guys was was holding the guy even
though that he'd been drugged up a
little he was just holding him and they
were at about 3,000 feet and this guy
started coming too and decided he was
not gonna be a prisoner so he started
kicking and squirming and biting the guy
in the face and and the old guy said
okay I guess you want that okay option
to 3,000 feet is turned him loose and
Washington disappear into the canopy so
that was somebody else's bad look on
there that wasn't mine
yeah and at this point you've got to be
close to your one-year run over there
and are you starting to feel any of the
any of the short time mentality you
start to think oh this is the last
mission when's the last one are you
starting to feel that at all
I started to feel not so much to the
last mission but I started to feel like
I mean they hit this compound from time
to time so I'd been over there you know
a year so I go to the supply room and I
say I'd like to sign out a flak jacket
in a steel pot no next time the siren
goes off and we head for the bunkers I'm
gonna have on the flak jacket and still
fight very so I don't have long left I
don't want to you know somebody's lucky
shot to take me out how many what was
that like last month you were there yeah
the last few weeks you're thinking I've
made it this far I'm not gonna get hit
by a flag did the compound because you
would see people I had another friend of
mine that had been with for a long time
before Mossad he only had a couple of
weeks left before he's going on and they
had a mission come up and he volunteered
to go on it and I said Pete what are you
doing he got two weeks man he said they
need a pretend leader to go out with his
company so I'm gonna do it and then I'm
out of here I was this last mission you
know so you see people like that so I
tried not to think of anything as this
is my last one this is what I'm going to
do this week of whatever it's not my
last one but I did think about yeah when
I'm running to that bunker maybe it's
still part of the flight deck it
wouldn't be okay you know this night
it's relatively cool so I'll be alright
so how did it how did the deployment so
I finished up and left there went back
down to the Train
you know to process out they told me no
you're gonna be stuck here for a couple
of weeks or so before we can get you on
the plane home so I went over to the SF
headquarters and I said I need help so
if there was an NCO there said what can
I do for you outside I need to get on a
plane tonight and he said let me see
what I can do yeah so I go out and party
with some other guys that I know and you
know about two o'clock in the morning
somebody's knocking on my door and this
guy's there saying I need you to to get
over I forgot what they call the place
you had to go through but you you need
to get over there right away so they can
process you through and get you on the
plane so are you captain now at this
point when you still first lieutenant
you're still a first lieutenant at this
point are you thinking you're stayed in
the army I'm thinking I may stick around
for a while I mean can he you know I had
thought it was gonna be three years but
when you get into an organization that
has the latest and greatest gadgets and
missions and esprit de corps I mean you
can't just walk away from there I mean
that's hard we're gonna walk - yeah it's
all fingers all bowed Hills nothing else
is like the guys that come back from
walking on the moon now what are you
gonna do yeah so I mean we had
everything from the little tiny grenades
much bigger than a jawbreaker that they
gave us the test I had a rocket fiscal
rocket this was a little expand it was
like it was like a little 10 gun that
you probably played with when you're a
kid that you stick a cork in the end of
it and you squeeze the little trigger
and it pops the cork out on a little
string so this thing popped out of 50
caliber round with a rock in the back of
it I mean and they gave us this and you
know what I thought this didn't make
much noise it sounds like shooting a
bottle rocket whoosh
I mean this thing's and big as your
thumb and it's solid steel I mean on the
outside steel case was it where they
build it for what was the purpose of it
to be something really quiet that had a
tremendous penetrating power so like you
would take a vehicle out weather or
something not a vehicle but you know did
you go right through a best I mean it
got unless I was right here if I shot
you with it right here it bounced off of
you because they wouldn't have it takes
about 10-15 feet to build up the speed
but beyond that I mean I shot it 32
two-by-fours
I mean you just couldn't stop it but you
know again I tried to use it and I think
I'll take the sky out because it's got
to be really quiet and so I get it up
and you know it's night and I go click
and you can hear the click no rocket you
know so when the other guys had to take
him out because this thing you didn't
work or so they got rid of those guys
they had you know such a malfunction
rate with I mean go google it little
rock the pistol rocket Pisco their video
is out there no people shoot them and
you know trying to make them work
sometimes they work sometimes they don't
so you're around your 3 is this around
your three-year mark you must be around
the 3 order hate you already relisted
her were you was realistic coming up
well because because I went to OCS then
I incurred you know extra time okay so
so I had to stick around and if I was
going to accept captain you know I had
to go indefinite so so so the weird
thing is you you're in Vietnam you're in
SOG you're conducting these crazy
operations you barely live through this
and then you you all of a sudden two
o'clock in the morning you're still
drunk probably you can't you it somebody
knocks on your door and says hey you're
going home yeah so then I get on I go
down and get on the plane every night
you know you're you're going through a
little security thing and the guy says
what's that in in your pants
and I said you mean this and he said yes
I said it's a war trophy and he says
okay I put it back down in my pants and
I got on that civilian aircraft and off
I go I'm thinking nobody's gonna hijack
this thing very gonna happen you know
got off the plane with it and San
Francisco or I think of the San
Francisco with or LA one of the Steven
you know went right on through there of
course you didn't have the security
checks there's like you know so so now
you're in either San Francisco you're
somewhere in California you're whatever
you're 48 hours or 72 hours or something
less than a couple days few days out of
the bush yeah how's that transition it's
tough I mean it's a it's a different
world back here aside from aside from
the protests and all that it's just a
totally different environment different
world you know I've come from the Wild
West I've come from a world where I
didn't have all these rules of
engagement that you have now the rule of
engagement was if I see you I kill you
you know if I run across somebody out in
the area of operations I terminate them
that's it
your your bad guy you don't have to have
a weapon you don't have to be doing
anything you know aggressive toward me I
just have to see you look guys you're
not supposed to see me so if I let you
see me then you know I basically signed
your death lon and now I'm in a world
where you can there are rules there are
laws there all kinds of things you can't
do that and what did the army this I
guess this is a loaded what did the army
do to help you reintroduce reintegrate
to being back in America at that point
the reintegration was here's your next
assignment you're going to be a ranger
instructor an arranger Department okay
I'm saying okay I can do that
you know I mean I probably wanted to be
a ranger instructor so I got that that
particular job and I thought you know
I've got maybe eight months at the most
mmm before I'm going to be back so what
better place to put me then as a ranger
instructor going out into evaluating
Ranger students on you know small
patrols tactics all that kind of stuff
and having a journal saying here's how I
can prove this technique that I used in
SOG here's how I can practice slipping
up on people more I can improve all the
techniques that I've been using there I
can go improve them I can spend more
time
you know it'll range using a range
shooting improve my marksmanship skills
my listening skills all night movement
skills I can go out and work on this
stuff for eight months journal it and
when I get back to SOG I'm gonna be a
better SOG guy than I was when I was
there before well tell you what we've
been going for another two hours and 40
minutes we're gonna pick up with your
Ranger Ranger instructor period of your
life on the next podcast okay good
thanks for coming on Thank You Franny
and yeah I think that's not just thanks
for coming honest thanks for everything
we'll talk to you on the next podcast
and thank you thank you echo well once
again Colonel Henry dick Thompson has
left the building and as once again left
me in a complete sense of awe because
we're talking about just absolute
insanity and the fact that the men of
SOG did what the men of SOG did and the
fact that the fact that we get to sit
here and talk to some of them is just
unbelievable because who who survives
what he did
who survives what tilt did who survives
what the Frenchman did not many and
that's something that we need to
remember as awesome as it is to sit here
and hear these stories remember that
they're not just stories that these were
people's lives and these or people's
deaths and so many of these men did not
return and they gave their lives so that
we can live ours and here we are forever
indebted to them to their sacrifice and
while I know that that we cannot ever
repay them
we can't it's just it's impossible but
what we do know is that the best we can
do to attempt to repay them is to live
our lives every day in a way that
venerates their sacrifices so don't just
live don't just be instead be everything
that you are capable of being
that's what we need to do
so echo I I guess that being everything
we are capable of being starts out with
us just being capable yes sir you like
that word capable yes well you went
through a whole like you went through a
whole capable oh yeah a whole kind of
yeah thing yeah yeah it's one of those
things that you cut kind of you latched
on to something that I said yes but then
you kind of you kind of adjusted it so
it made sense to you yeah you know you
know clear way yeah and I would say even
more accurately put like where I latched
onto it exactly good way of putting I
latched on to it and then just sort of
like you know how you go down that
wormhole more and learn more and more so
yeah and that and playing the long game
versus the short that's another those
are the two Thea
for sure because that's really what it
kind of is it's like it's almost like
every decision you make most decisions
that you make are gonna land unlike one
of those things like okay and a lot of
times both of them so you're like okay
am I gonna play the long game here the
short game and that's everything pretty
much and then the other one who do I
want to be capable or comfortable right
that's the other two like okay and if
you can kind of keep that in your mind
your decision-making would be a lot
better yeah for yourself you know it's
interesting though this little this
little play on words a little that's a
little bit of a play on words I just
said right if you want to be everything
you're capable of being well it starts
with just being capable in the first
place yes
where do we need to be capable and how
can we improve our capabilities
physically mentally and emotionally
spiritually and spiritually I think yes
because some people will tell you no not
spiritually really pull them again what
is let me tell you what you mean let me
tell you Jiu Jitsu will definitely help
you in all aspects let's think about
this pragmatically confidence yes if you
know Jiu Jitsu you will be more
confident this is now you'll take a
little you'll start off by taking a
little bit
step back in confidence because when you
very first start training you're gonna
be overwhelmed by the fact that you're
gonna be scared of everyone looking at
them going wait this guy might know
jiu-jitsu and then they can beat me
yeah then after a little while you go
okay no cool even if this person just
knows jujitsu I at least know what to do
a little bit yes so so confidence is
definitely to help you stress relief we
talked about that last time it's
definitely to help you capability is
definitely to help you yeah so it's
gonna help you across the board
that social aspect is gonna help you
okay go ahead sorry back to dr. Thompson
mm-hmm and and you know all the SOG guys
work well actually a lot of guys that
we've talked to whatever I kind of trip
out like when I go home in this in a lot
of ways but in this particular way we're
you know how like in the movies right
where you got the guy and he's also
about to get killed
Yeah right but in the back your mind
you're like unless this movie's gonna
kill this character which they're not if
it's the main character right
I was just way at the end and that's a
difference but you know it's in the
middle of the movie or whatever and he's
about to get found out by the mad guys
can't get found and killed or whatever
dude you're like okay this is good the
way they presented and everything and
I'm sure it's suspenseful but the back
of my mind like they're not gonna kill
this guy
you know so you kind of get that feeling
when they're telling this story but it's
like a real story yeah and then that's
why that's why you know what I was
thinking about this like it's cool it's
so awesome to sit here and talk to these
guys that lived yeah but you have to
remember that there's countless guys
that the exact scenario that these guys
went through where oh the bullet went
two inches to the left instead of two
inch to the right and that guy is dead
the helicopter got hit with this the
helicopter crash like it's it's just
it's that's why it's such a miracle that
these guys are sitting here talking to
us yeah and that's what I mean then
that's why I'm actually tripping out
because sure we know the guy live
because he's sitting right here we know
that part of it but when he takes you
back to the moment but we really don't
know if this guy is gonna live or not
yeah yeah I mean as far as themselves
you know and then I trip out even more I
kind of go down a little wormhole
like man this is just how impossible
this is not impossible maybe that's not
the right word but it kind of feels like
there anyway but just how weird this is
where let's say you went back in time
and visited you know tilt or whoever and
said hey this is what you're gonna do
and these very specific things are gonna
happen and you're gonna live even him
him himself would be like I don't know
that's possible yeah yeah for sure
meanwhile it's actually happened yeah it
kind of puts a lot of things into
perspective yeah yeah it's it's crazy
duh
those guys are just unbelievable and
that story from from dick Thompson that
I read today just going in to rescue
with no plan with no somebody else's
weapon it's just like completely just
dropping 15 feet into 150 foot of jungle
canopy falling through the trees until
you luckily hit a branch and so you
don't by the way if you hit the ground
without hitting anything you just die
just die yeah and and and so yeah these
guys are just they're just awesome
there's awesome human beings you know
yeah and then you kind of you sort of
see them sitting across you when you're
like in this there he is
yeah this is the guy who did that for
real stuff you know yeah thank you what
about those old pictures of tilt which
tilts like 2022 years old
you just look at those ago that's like
the coolest guy ever
and you see pictures to get all these
guys the Frenchman with his with his
legs all taped up and you see dick
Thompson dick Thompson was lucky off
yeah uh was he a first lieutenant I
thought it was cool on the first podcast
when I was asking about how like when
you volunteered was there any resistance
he's like no he's volunteering to be an
officer in Vietnam the life expectancy
was a couple weeks they're like oh you
wanna be an officer cool we'll step
right over here into this line oh you
want to be go to Ranger schools cool
step through this I know you want to be
Special Forces cool step into this line
oh you want to go to
SOG cool no problem step over here
there's zero resistance zero resistance
for him to go and do what he wanted to
do because the life expectancy of every
one of those it's just like volunteer to
volunteer to volunteer to to be dead
yeah and there's no resistance so well
very capable people were talking about
here yeah mentally physically
emotionally and spiritually 100% the
last factor jiu-jitsu yes covers all
those things and we should be doing this
in my opinion so we need keys when we do
jujitsu
cuz it that's part of the uniform you
get an origin gate don't even have to
ask that question no longer a question
no no longer a question or gingy go to
origin mein kampf boom pick whatever you
want easy money also they also have rash
guards on their other clothing items
there cuz you want to represent you know
being in an american-made clothing
mm-hmm but you can't wear your ghee to
the store unfortunately yeah I mean you
cook text not recommended you you could
technically but usually the cutoff for
that or is around 11 years old yes like
my dog my little 10 year old daughter
she's walking around and I know fabulous
enough yeah no one says anything to her
she's not like she's not like walking
around trying to be proved that she's a
jiu-jitsu player no I mean it's kind of
evident that she's a Jew too but cuz she
is wearing Aggie but you know it's no
factor she'll go to dinner with Aggie on
you know well you know okay I guess it
depends circumstances she's table I
think her cutoff is 11 yes when she
turns 11 chill probably like I'm gonna
take off my gear ight now yeah well if
you come to straight from jujitsu and
you're like hey let's pick up so she's
not going hey we're going out for dinner
on the house let me put my key oh yeah
no she's not doing that I wouldn't be
bothered if she did you know what I mean
it's my son wore a dang a dang Superman
uniform for like two straight years when
he was you know five years old five and
six yes
we're no a ding Captain America outfit
just walking around you just go to
school with that it had the muscles in
it you know I mean oh they just walks
real cost yeah yeah a first-rate costume
he's just walking around and whatever
Koopman I dig it and my other daughter
wore a dang - - you know that is it's
like a ballerina outfit
ballerina uniform and she was you wore
that thing all the time yes whatever
yeah she's just no factor so what I'm
saying is different when you get past
age 10 maybe 11 you don't want to wear
your key to the store to the restaurant
but you still in your heart you want to
represent your good because we got
origin genes you got the origin genes
you can get the regular weight genes or
you can get the Delta 68 genes which are
I guess they're the Jocko signature
model yeah maybe but if they're thinner
and thinner yeah technically isn't that
a fashion thing I'm not saying this
particular thing is the fashion thing
I'm saying being thinner fashion jeans
tend to be thinner okay well I don't
know about that what I do know is this I
live in California
mm-hmm it's warmer here mmm we don't
always need to wear thicker jeans so we
get jeans that are lightweight just like
when you're in the military which you
weren't so you wouldn't know anything
about about field camis about how they
used to have woodland camis they had a
lightweight and they had a heavyweight
you don't know about that so I do you so
guess what we have lightweight jeans and
I'll say the other ones are medium
though normal the other jeans are just
normal jeans yeah the the Delta 68 named
after my forefathers and the SEAL Teams
that wore jeans in the Mekong Delta for
the year yeah that's a good Delta 68
yeah so get the Delta 68 jeans if you
need something that's a little bit
lighter weight not for fashion yeah I
guess if your echo Charles you can do it
for fashion but if you're a normal human
fashion - hey potentially we'll just say
look you know Pete sprinkled some
fashion in there
you know that watch your factual
Tim like a hawk you know but there's no
there's no fashion on the Delta 68 jeans
are you sure about that yeah I'm
positive
all right well I'm gonna when I change
my Delta 68 jeans if that ever happens
I'm gonna make a evaluation you know
report back but my hypothesis is that if
Pete has anything to do with it which
incidentally he does he sprinkled some
fashion I got a I got a watch that guy
like a sniper because he will constantly
try and no surprise they're not
bell-bottoms bringing them that yeah I
dig it and you're you're correct you're
not wrong you're right but you're like
you you know you eat steak right what do
you put on your steak steak like what do
you put on there salt and pepper on
there what okay so they're pretty basic
salt and pepper right so you know people
they'll put like a special seasoning
they got their special rub right are you
with that
are you just like whatever or kind of go
to whatever I'm not anti I'm not hating
them but I'm not it seems unnecessary to
me okay so here's the comparison that
what Pete does with fashion what people
could do with steak okay let's say
you're the kind of person who's like
salt and pepper that's my jam
don't touch my steak otherwise medium or
me or whatever you'd like to cook salt
the pepper that's all you put your
stupid rub seasoning on it you're
messing up my whole stinking cuz I'm
saying you know people right like that
yeah and I dig it and that's you know
that's you think Pete is the kind guy
will be like hey no problem I got you
salt and pepper that's it but he knows
confidently that if you put some of that
special rub on there you'll like it
there
not as far as you're concerned oak don't
touch it and then he'll be like okay I
got you he does you kidding you're 100%
accurate yeah do that yeah and there's
there's been times where I've been like
bro he put too much seasoning on now
stop what you're doing but I think I
think you spray he sneaks it in there's
good and then when you taste the steak
you're like the ink Pete makes a great
steak not even realize he snuck in the
rub yeah that's what he does with the
fashioned with you douche I hope he
doesn't hear this which I know he will
is now he's gonna get excited about it
and think he can sneak in more you
I'm watching you like a sniper yes I got
eyes on bro me so genes I say Pete do
what you do breath do it just don't take
it too far
yeah the genes are good I like and this
is how I know about the genes too cuz
when I put them on it's like okay my
wife is kind of critical she's from the
Pacific Northwest my way so she knows
about just functional genes for work and
like all that stuff she's just in but
she's you know she's number one yeah you
know she's dead she and she gets it I'm
speaking for her by the way but she
doesn't like it she don't like the look
you remind her you know those are dad
jeans and you know my dad's a worker or
whatever she don't like the look is not
sane so I put on the origin jeans if she
didn't like them she would tell me
hundred percent she probably wouldn't
even let me be seen with her which I can
respect on a certain level and she even
said those jeans look good interesting
so man approved in my household approve
looks like the line the spice right
perfect also what else does origin have
and supplements obviously keep us on
track in the game even when you get
older if you're old school and you ask
am I too old to join you - nope us
working with a tech company yesterday
and they were talking about age and
everyone there was young and they were
like saying I can oh no there's some
older people here like late 40s and I'm
like hey how's it going pretty funny
but yes here's the thing one thing that
can help you is these supplements join
more foreign oil the discipline
discipline go there definitely
beneficial if you think you might forget
first of all take more discipline but
second of all subscribe you can do the
subscription thing on Origin main comm
and then you just get it just shows up
just just make it a standard operating
procedure done yeah then you don't fall
off you know how long I've gone without
joint warfare for never I take it every
day that's good yes yes I'm with krill
oil
you mentioned forgetting so you know how
like you when I forget to take it like
you kind of look at me crazy-like proud
look how do you forget you just yeah
it's not hard to forget a toothpaste or
one might are you always more important
to you right but it's not really true
because if you're in a certain routine
and this goes to your point where if you
don't roll that into your routine you
will forget even if it's important
because there's certain times of the day
or certain times the moments in life or
whatever that you do like bright you
know when you're driving yes when you're
driving home right you'll forget the
whole experience of driving home because
you're thinking other stuff like
routinely or whatever in you like oh
shoot I don't remember one single moment
of driving home really you just did not
a matter yet you live you live the ass
what livings not important whoa driving
homes not Airport yeah it's very
important but it's just so routine
assume saying so like I said if taking
the krill oil giant warfare is not
rolled into your routine you can
potentially forget it so roll it into
your routine mm-hmm subscribe and and
you you actually save money if you
subscribe to so do that
don't forget about the red unit drink
cans you don't need to drink these hyped
up energy drinks anymore
that are that are literally not good for
you you can now drink something that
isn't good for you you know tastes
delicious gives you a little give you
need that little later
it's a milder taste to than the energy
drink scenario yeah yeah so what it kind
of allows you I mean I'm assuming this
is why it allows you to drink like more
of them
be careful with it I'm saying but you
know the kind of where you drink two of
them will say for like about a
traditional energy drinks you drink two
of those you don't feel good afterwards
no you feel like crap even if you're
into energy drinks typically yeah you
kind of those are just like men you can
kind of have one going yep good yeah so
you and don't forget about milk all
different kinds of protein desserts it's
just straight desserts for you for your
warrior kid milk for your kids get some
of that and then we got the white tea
gonna get you through the winter months
with the warm white tea and get the
canned white tea and of course the
benefit is eight thousand pound deadlift
a post-assad you know that yep
also speaking of benefits kind of
chocolate store it's called your cool
store that's where you can't get shirts
why is that beneficial because it's
speaking of benefits not presenting I
thought what you were gonna say is
there's a guy that said his wife said to
him what do you want for your birthday
hmm and he said there's a store it's
called Jaffa store she was like yeah in
my mind yes she said check did she
probably said okay what's that yeah good
and yeah you can get shirts it is
beneficial
cuz especially nowadays like you can get
right you can I think nowadays and I
don't say the word fashion necessarily
I'm saying but what you wear as well
what you wear
we're gonna shut down the store the way
what you wear it's not it's not a
fashion store it's not but what you wear
is like you have many options right like
in life I'm saying you can wear it just
a blank shirt if you want you know so
you kind of look for a little bit more
than just the well I guess you can look
for a lot of things anyway one of the
things that this as far as this stuff
that you can get it kinda is
representative of a certain how should I
say not message but a certain discourse
okay yeah so anyways what you can get
his t-shirts rash guards hats but not
just any t-shirt though yeah what I'm
saying good quality ones good quality
100% yes given but you know there's a
little added layer to what you're
wearing is there is there a placebo
effect when you wear a shirt that says
discipline equals freedom yes does it
affect your your mentality technically
yes it is because it is I guess
technically a placebo effect but that's
how right or is it just a real effect
it's a real effect the effect is a real
event it's kind of like um like like
hypnosis or something like this Yeah
right that's a real effect to most of
the time sometimes it's just a show but
the effect the result is real that's
where we get the nineteen percent
increased strength and performance
mental acuity yes with the rash guard
with the t-shirts yeah actually we're up
to 22 percent now okay yeah that
happened last year late last year yeah
up 22 percent improved everything mental
physical and spiritual and social by the
way okay with all these items anyway
chocolate or calm sure it's t-shirts
rash guards uh hoodies hats beanies I
said all this stuff bro
well there's your reminder bulb dr.
4.com also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already if you want there
you go stitcher iTunes what not also if
there's not enough of this podcast to
listen to which really means you have a
long commute you can also check out the
grounded podcast which is a different
podcast that we do it's called grounded
yes we talked about jujitsu life
experience humor and other things and
other things and here's a good Elega to
back me up on other things
it's true because there are some
elements of that that I did notice that
you know how there's like issues not
necessarily controversial you're super
hype on the grounded copy vodka yes
because I think it's cuz you kind of
like you feel like you're a little bit
of the star of the gun no I don't feel
like I will start at all actually I feel
like that I you will allow me maybe not
anymore
but you will allow me to introduce
elements to it that kind of have two
sides to it you know and then I can you
can kind of see okay where does people
where do people fall on this issue not
important issues by the way but so yes I
am woodsy hyped you're high yeah I guess
I listen to the ground and podcast like
rewind and replay your parts again no
anyway how about this let's just say I
highly recommend now on okay good don't
forget about the warrior kid podcast we
got some new episodes coming your way
we'll say in the near future and don't
forget to get some more your kids soap
you can support an actual warrior kid
out there running a business young Aiden
making soap so that you can stay clean
Irish Oaks ranch calm you also YouTube
you're interested in the video version
of this pod can't see what dick Thompson
looks like oh yeah yes or anyone you
know anyone on the on the podcast that
we interview or each other if you don't
know what chocolate looks like yeah and
then we have psychological warfare which
is a little mental support psychological
support if you find yourself in a moment
of weakness you can just press play on
your on your phone and you'll get to
listen a little guidance from me that's
available on Google Play iTunes mp3
platforms of all kinds if you need to
have these you will reminder to stay on
the path check out flipside canvas
dot-com from my brother Dakota Meyer
podcast 115 by the way he makes these
things here in America you gonna flip
side canvas calm
get one books got some books first of
all stress effect again we haven't hit
it yet but the next podcast with Colonel
dick Thompson we will be covering the
stress effect so you can get that book
it's on the website it's also on Amazon
but you can click through our website
chuckle podcast.com and then you can get
the book the stress effect and then
there's leadership strategy tactics is
in my new book I have coming out which
is actually very granular here's a
little section from it part two this is
just from the contents part to
leadership tactics one becoming a leader
how to succeed as a new leader how to be
chosen to lead when you are not chosen
impostor syndrome insecurity as a leader
transitioning from follower or peer to
leader overcoming a grudge new sheriff
in town don't go overboard
Rambo so there's some topics that are in
the new leadership strategy and tactics
book if you want to get a copy of it try
and get a first edition you need to
order it right now because otherwise
when it comes out January 14th Amazon is
gonna send you a note that says you all
cool jock whose book came out today I'm
gonna order it you'll go on there it'll
say it's a shipping in three to eight
weeks and you're gonna go waters wrong
with the logistics train Jacko's
horrible and I'll say yeah I know I
didn't do a good job of convincing you
when you needed to order the book so I
failed
so let me not fail by getting on there
and helping me to help you and then of
course we got the warrior Kid books one
two and three these are books with that
I wish I had when I was a kid and if I
promised you when you read it you're
saying I wish I would have had this book
on it you might even be in a full-on
adult and say I wish I learned these
lessons way the warrior kid one way the
warrior kid two marks mission away the
warrior kid three where there's a will
so check those out if you've got a
little kid in your life somewhere
a little bit younger maybe six years old
five years old seven years old three
years old
get them Mikey in the Dragons they're
actually gonna learn a pragmatic
technique to overcome fear which if you
remember being a little kid life is
filled with fear so how do you overcome
that you get Mikey and the Dragons
that's what you do
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
there's the Christmas present there's
the Christmas present you want to get
for someone that may be drifted off the
path maybe they're having a hard time
maybe life isn't going good maybe they
could do better maybe you know that
discipline would help them in their life
get him the discipline equals freedom
Field Manual simple as that and then for
leadership we got extreme ownership we
got dichotomy of leadership I wrote
those with my brother Leif Babbitt it's
about what we learned on the battlefield
and how you can apply it to your life to
win to your business to win to your
company to win I also have a leadership
consultancy it's called a salon front
and what we do is we solve problems
through leadership that is what we do so
go to Ashland front comm for details if
you want to have someone from the team
come and speak at your company don't go
to a speaker's bureau no you go to a
salon front comm you cut out the
middleman and you go right to the
company that's what we do you don't need
to Google Jaakko speaker because you're
gonna get somewhere you'll see ISIL on
front you won't know what it is maybe
and you goes click on someone else and
then they charge you a big chunk of
money on top of what I'm gonna charge
don't do that go to Ashland front comm
we also have online training because
leadership training is not an
inoculation you don't get one shot and
now you're good to go no it takes time
it takes reps get the reps in see it
again seen it from a different angle
EF online.com and then we got mustard
dates coming for 20 20 go to extreme
ownership calm this is our leadership
seminar our Leadership Conference come
and check that out and of course EF
overwatch and EF Legion the
or our placement platforms where we are
taking military personnel and putting
them into civilian organizations so that
they can help those organizations lead
at every level and win go to EF
overwatch comm or EF Legion comm that is
what you need is leadership and if you
need more of us or you have questions
for us or you have answers for us you
can find all of us on the interwebs dick
Thompson is on twitter at h PS
underscore CEO and at HP sy s comm
high-performance systems that's his
company and of course we are also on
twitter instagram and deep phrasing box
echo is adequate Charles and I am at
Jocko willing and once again sincere
thanks and appreciation to dick Thompson
for coming on this program and sharing
his lessons with us and of course we
thank him for his incredible service and
sacrifice to our great nation and that
goes to all the rest of our servicemen
and women who stand the watch against
evil and against tyranny so that we can
be here living in freedom into our
police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all the first responders all of you that
are out there risking your lives for us
thank you for standing the watch over us
here at home so we can sleep safely at
night and everyone else out there ask
yourself that question what are you
capable of being what are you capable of
being and are you doing everything in
your power to
be the most capable human being you can
be I know when I asked myself that
question I know the answer I know I can
do more I know I can we can all do more
and that starts each and every day by
getting up going on the attack and
getting after it and until next time
this is echo and Jocko out